Riyle justical's editor retweets bad
empanada and posts his stuff in other
subreddits about empanada docs a few
days ago how it's that we can put them
all together we can all we can connect
it all so rile was bad empanada the
whole time apparently our our good
friend of the stream logic is allowing a
bunch of doxing and degenerate to happen
in spicy chat right oh I don't like that
word consent violator what no I'm not a
consent violator I have a gooner
lifestyle guys I don't I don't just like
habitually ually violate consent. I have
a gooner lifestyle. Man, I'm really
scared that she might be underage cuz
that's the only thing that'll sink me
here. I can sweep the rest of it away. I
can sweep the rest of it away. But if
she's under if she's under 18, I can't
sweep that away. All VTubers/ streamers
who use those bouncy cartoon rant sonas
need to be put into camps now.
Okay, so Destiny went over a bunch of
his like lawsuit stuff today. went over
some thoughts on like doxing and uh it's
okay. It's whatever. But I'm I'm going
to cover that. We'll see. We'll see how
it goes. Where I have the link here.
Where I Where's the link at? Where' I
put it? Destiny.
Okay, cool.
Okay. It starts somewhere around here.
He first starts talking about his legal
cases and
starts talking about the legal cases and
then he slowly like weaves into talking
about like doxing and stuff and it's
just crazy to me that nobody in his
audience asks for any evidence of any of
the things he says. He just gets to like
make things up and then even when they
do ask for evidence, it'll be like this
person this person is guilty of murder
or something is what he'll say. Okay,
this is a hypothetical. This person's
guilty of murder and people go wait is
there evidence of that? and he'll go,
"Yeah, I have a picture of them in the
hotel where the person was murdered that
day." And they'll go, "Oh, yeah, they
are guilty of murder, aren't they?" Oh
my god, Destiny. Destiny just proved
they're guilty of murder. And it's like,
"No, he didn't. He proved that they're
like in the same hotel as the as the
person who got What are you saying? How
do you lose all critical thinking
capability when it's Destiny saying it
like one tiny piece of evidence with no
other connection, right?
It's it's wild. Anyway, so we'll have
stuff like that. That'll be coming up."
game.
>> This is a quick meme because I saw some
people discussing this.
>> My best friend was on uh Twitter
yesterday having an epic.
>> We talked about the Abby thing. Yeah. Uh
Abby posted some stuff on Twitter and
then deleted her account. I was like
>> people are arguing whether or not you
have to respond to a subpoena um for a
civil case. So one generally they
require some kind of response.
You don't always have to respond to a
subpoena, but obviously if you give an
affidavit, you that's literally a part
of that affidavit is that you're willing
to testify in court. Um, but people are
talking about whether you have to be
involved in a case or if it's your
choice or what not. The thing is is that
this is not like a random person who's
being subpoenaed to join the case. This
is somebody who has filled out an
affidavit. They've attached a
declaration swearing that they would
testify to this in court. So yes, they
do have to make themselves available for
deposition. You cannot
you can't like um you can't say
something fill out an affidavit attack.
>> This is just this is just true that you
can't fill out an affidavit and then
refuse to appear in court. That's not
how that works. I'm pretty sure I'm
pretty sure part of the affidavit is you
saying I will show up and testify to
these facts in in a court of law. Now
they can ask to depose. I'm not totally
sure about depositions or what that
means exactly if that's like before a
jury. I I don't know the exact way that
works out. I would assume you should be
able to depose them as the opposing
side, but
>> it to some lawsuit and then dodge
service or subpoena until the day of the
trial and then just show up like we have
a right to depose um an opposing person.
Also, just as a heads up too, um not
that this matters and this is all just
federal rules of civil procedure, I
still don't have like half the that
these losers have filed to the court. Um
they haven't made any of it available to
us. all of those things that you see
where they've got like redacted names
and for like half of these I've never
gotten an original that's been sent to
me.
>> Okay. So, first of all, he's saying I've
never gotten an original that was sent
to me. So, I assume what happened was
they were doing the the ceiling. Okay. I
would I would be very curious there if
Destiny has not gotten it sent to him,
but if it's been sent to his lawyer,
right?
So, he's saying, "Oh, they haven't sent
anything to me." I believe the
protective order they're filing for is
so that they don't have to give you
names, right? I think that's the goal is
they don't want to give you names. Mr.
Mutton back in DG. I don't care. I'm not
talking about Mr. Moot. Okay. Um I
believe that's the whole point of the
protective order is so they don't have
to give you names so that Andrew can get
them but you shouldn't get them. That's
like the entire purpose, right? So I
would imagine they're not sending you
those names while the order or while the
filing for the protective order is
happening.
Um I like it's just which you're not
allowed to do. It's not you're not
allowed to do that. It's violating the
rules of civil procedure. But yeah, this
was funny. I don't know why she
admitted. Well, probably she didn't
realize it was probably not a good thing
to do. But why didn't the judge if it's
violating the rules of civil procedure?
Why didn't the judge mention it to them?
[Applause]
Can they get away with that though? No.
But I don't They're not trying to like
Can they get away with that though? The
Yes. You literally got mocked by their
lawyer who said, "Obviously, we didn't
violate rules of civil procedure on this
because nobody cares."
They The lawyer took the time to mock
you in the filing. What are we talking
about? Can they get away with this? Uh,
can they get away? I assume if Abby
won't testify anywhere at all, then her
her testimony will be inadmissible.
It's not about getting away with
Nobody's getting away with something.
People are like looking at this as a
case that they're trying to win, but
they're not trying to win it. They're
just trying to drag this out as much as
possible. Like it wouldn't surprise me
if they got a bunch of bad rulings on
these upcoming motions. If they did,
that they would like dismiss the case.
Like I have no faith in them actually
handing over like what we've asked for
in Discovery. I don't think they'll do
it. Um, and if they do, I think they'll
hide and obscure stuff.
>> So now Destiny, Destiny basically was of
the opinion that when he is the only
person holding his logs, when he deletes
all of his logs and he's the only person
holding them, that that means nothing
bad happened, right? Guys, I would never
edit these things. And now he's doing
the same thing back, he's like, "Oh,
actually, even if they give us the stuff
that like we subpoenaed, well, I think
that would all be like edited and
changed and and they delete stuff."
Actually,
>> um, I don't think they're even trying to
win at trial. I think they're just doing
everything they can to survive the
motion for summary judgement so that
they can drag it out.
>> They want to go to discovery. This, by
the way, this case has always and
forever been about going to Discovery to
get evidence from Google or Discord that
the video has been sent again, right?
Like that's been what it's been about
the entire time. Hey, we need we need a
a suit so we can go to Google and
Discord and see if you've sent this
video, Pixie. That's the entire purpose
of the suit, right?
Hey, this is outside of uh this is
outside but we have people willing to
testify that you sent these things right
within the within the Cardi statute
limit uh not statute limit but after
Cardi was passed this we're just looking
to get to discovery. We want to get to
discovery and then we're going to
subpoena your records from Discord and
Google and then we'll just see what
happens. Right. Like like basically if
you didn't send it then I guess we we
lose our federal jurisdiction or
whatever. But that's been the entire
thing. They just want to go to
Discovery. Yes.
right? Based on, hey, we have people
saying that you sent this video to them.
We want to go to Discovery and see if
that's if that's a thing that happened.
It's not confusing,
right? Pixie was wronged. Are we Are we
pretending that you didn't say you
violated her trust in the worst possible
way? Are we pretending that she wasn't
wronged? She's absolutely wronged.
And now she's like, "I believe you've
wronged me again. Here's my evidence for
that. Here's people who are saying that
you wronged me again. I want to charge
you under this law and and look for this
in discovery." out as long as like I
think that's it.
>> So the idea that they want to survive
summary judgement is obvious. That's
been what what plaintiff doesn't want to
survive summary judgement before going
to trial.
Did you guys know Listen this is this is
Destiny POV. Okay. Destiny I'll do my
Perry impression. Destiny Destiny
Destiny be like Destiny be like uh oh
Destiny play soccer. Desi's playing
soccer. Okay, guys. Dessi's playing
soccer. And when the other team tries to
score on him, he says, "Oh, look at them
trying to score on me and win the game.
I'm being wronged." Okay, that's what's
happening. They're literally playing by
the rules. They're doing exactly what
they're supposed to do. And he's like,
"I'm being wronged. I am now a victim."
Come on, man.
I got to work on my Perry impression.
It could be better.
I think it's more incompetence than
intentional. No, it is intentional. It's
not incompetence. It is intentional. The
Zabby person is like pretty clearly like
mentally unwell and they absolutely
roped her in with Wait,
it's pretty clearly mentally unwell.
Wait, why did you invite her to your
home and leave her with all of your
stuff apparently unlocked
if she's so clearly mentally unwell?
How many How many times in a row could
you make the same excuse? Okay, bro.
Take a shot. Take a shot. Take a shot.
Zabby person is like pretty clearly like
mentally unwell and they absolutely
roped her in with like an absolute
claim.
They roped her in with an absolute
claim. Where is the Abby has been
consistent in her testimony the entire
time. The exact testimony that she
provided is the testimony that she can
provide, right? Like is the evidence she
can provide. There's no there's nothing
in her testimony from her affidavit. He
keeps lying about this. He just lies,
right? He's just openly lying. She said
she has contemporaneous evidence of you
sharing it. As in she told other people
about it, right? She told other people
that you shared these videos with her
from that time from before she could
know that the video's existence and she
said your side of the logs were deleted,
but she could provide her side of the
logs.
What's confusing? That's been the whole
time. That's been what she said she has.
Why would Destiny if that's not enough
to survive summary judgement or if
that's like a problem, right? Or sorry,
if that's not a problem and that's, you
know, not evidence of anything, then
what is he mad about? That's all she
claimed. Like, you have to know how it
is if you're trying to rope in a witness
who is literally telling you I I
literally can't prove anything that I'm
saying right now. And
what what does he think she tried to
prove?
He again like you could you could make
this argument if you're really dumb. You
can make this argument, right? She
didn't pro she doesn't have, you know,
exported Discord logs of the exact
videos that are at play here. You could
say that, but that's never been their
claim or her claim or anyone's claim.
So, you're fighting against a total
straw man that you're making up.
Why Why do you even care about this? If
it's all like total like proof of
nothing, if it all means nothing, then
shouldn't the court just decide that in
your fa in your favor? And also I might
have gone through his entire computer
and there might be like photographic
evidence of me doing that when I was at
his house. Like oh
also I went through notice also I went
through his computer and there may be
photographic evidence of me doing that
at his house. This is this is I it might
not be the first instance but this is an
instance of guys I have evidence Abby
murdered somebody. The evidence is Abby
having a picture a photo in the hotel
where the person was murdered that day.
Right? So, if you want to know evidence
that she went through my computer is
this precisely. Hold on, let me let me
grab this.
This is uh I can find this in another
tab real quick. This is I I saw this in
the tweet thread with Ellie B and the
other people the other day.
So, evidence that she went through my
computer is that she posted a photo in
in this with Darius. Okay. Not to big
any big not to any big stream plans. Are
you already on the way home? Apparently,
this is to Darius. Okay. Now I'm
chilling in Destiny's apartment until my
flight he left. Soon though, I'm him.
Major leaks prob. So major leaks
problem. And she posts this. She's like,
"Oh, this is a picture of his computer."
I have no evidence she went through
anything on this computer. One wonders
why you would leave somebody who you
think is clearly mentally ill with your
computer unlocked like right after a
stream, right? He clearly just finished
streaming, but she's sitting in his
chair looking at his computer and
saying, "Oh, I might be leaking stuff on
his computer by taking a picture of
this." Right? His Discord's open. This
stuff's open. There's no evidence she
went through any of this. I see no
evidence. And and the thing I'd just be
curious about is so we're going to get
to this later where he says he says
major leagues pro. What is what is after
this? If you have all these logs, why
aren't there more logs here? Where are
the rest of the logs? Are you saying
that she just sat there and did nothing?
I'm saying I don't know what she did,
but clearly she's saying major leagues
Prague. Shouldn't there be major leaks
coming?
If that's what your assertion is, she's
going to go through his computer and
leak a bunch of things. She's going to
go through his computer. Where's the
rest of the messages?
Why don't we have those? Didn't she
admit to Darius that she went through
it? Or am I misremembering? Well, this
is the evidence that she admitted to
Darius that she went through it or
something. I don't see the other
evidence. She might have. I have no
idea. I'm just saying that when he says
she did that, she admitted she did that.
I don't think she did. And this is the
evidence I've been shown so far.
And it's this picture. Now, I have no
idea what Abby did. Apparently, and I
don't think Abby denies it. Apparently,
she took a picture of some Molina
journal or something, which seems like a
violation of privacy, right?
But I don't I don't see any evidence
that she went through this and saw like
the things that you're claim like a
video pixie or something. By the way,
the video Pixie couldn't possibly be
here, could it? Where did she go? Where
where would it show up here?
The video Pixie was sent like a year
earlier or something, right?
The video pixie sent a year earlier. Why
would it be anywhere here at all?
What would you need her saying? I went
through his What do you mean? I I would
need her saying I went through his
computer looking for stuff, but I would
also need some evidence that she saw the
pixie video. Where would the pixie video
be? Here
is that Discord. I literally pointed to
the Discord being open.
I'm assuming if she's looking to leak
stuff, if she's snooping on his
computer, that she would have said
something about it. She doesn't say
anything about what could what he
alleges could be there until 2 months
later.
But there are people here like Lexer Q
who has a impression in his brain. He's
totally right. Totally. There are people
like this guy who are like, "No, no, no.
Desi says uh Desi says this happened."
Destiny says he found these videos by
looking at his Discord or something.
Didn't Abby say something about Abby has
testified to precisely this? Hold on. Do
I have I think I have her testimony here
somewhere.
This is a Bretler testimony. Do I have
her testimony somewhere here? Let me
find the Dabby testimony here. Hold on.
Uh, where's witness A here?
Let me find this. What she what she
testifies to is she says she was sent
videos by him, right? That's what that's
what's sent. Where is it? Where is it?
Where is it? I'll find it. Don't worry.
Oh my god.
Witness A and B.
Oh my god. Is Sya here? If Cyber is
here, I would take this. But I don't see
I literally don't see these exhibits on
their behalf right now. I'm blind. Give
me a second.
Plaintiff's declaration. It's not this
one. No, here it is. Oh, here it is. I
found it. Right.
Yes. Okay.
This is it. This is all Aby's ever
claimed. Okay. We're going to go through
exactly what Aby's claimed. All right.
On her about November 3rd, 2023, Destiny
shared through a Google Drive link a
explicit video that included himself and
another streamer, Pixie, the plaintiff
in this action. I recognized Pixie in
the video because I had seen her post on
Instagram and had seen her on Destiny's
live streams and on her own live
streams.
her face and hair or her face and hair
is visible in the video and that is how
I recognized her honor about no so I was
sent this video on about November 20 uh
3rd 2023 I messaged a friend of mine and
said that I've been sent this video okay
and then here it's like I recently
reviewed my Discord account and realized
Destiny deleted all of his direct
messages to me on the Discord platform
including the sharing of the video Pixie
I retained copies of all of my messages
as well as my messages to other people
about his non-consensual sharing of
explicit videos this is what she said
she had Okay. So, Destiny tells people
that she claimed she had proof that he
sent this. She didn't. She said, "I have
contemporaneous evidence of this and I
have my side of the logs because he has
deleted his logs."
That's that's the claim.
It's like not confusing to anyone what
she's claimed. Right.
But he he pretends that Abby came and
said, "I have proof that he sent this to
me. I have like like shot proof." No,
but the question is is how does Abby
tell people in 2023 that these things
that won't be leaked until late 2024
exist? How does she know about the
existence of a Pixie video?
How does she tell people about it?
How is she able to do that?
All right, hold on. Let me see. This is
This is what she did. She told a friend
here. By the way, Destiny sends me tapes
all the time and he thinks I don't know
the girls in them, but I have videos of
him Cherry and Pixie like Lafoul. He
just sent me another one. Haven't opened
it. Let's see who's this time. This is
what she said, right?
Same reason Lav did. It was just a good
guess. Clueless. Yeah, exactly.
But the cherry vid, isn't it sound only?
So, she said this back here, right? But
she said in the testimony that it's
sound only. She said in the testimony by
just by her voice because it's a black
screen with audio.
So she says in the testimony that it was
audio,
but I don't the the cherry thing is not
even relevant to this case, right? I
thought I thought Destiny's whole point
is the cherry thing isn't relevant to
this case. Why would he even look at
that? Why would we just look at the
pixie thing? How does How does she know
the Pixie thing exists?
Can anybody tell me? How does she know
the pixie thing exists? Lexer Q, I want
you to tell me how she knows the Pixie
thing exists.
Go ahead.
I just want to I just want to see what
he says. I just want to see.
Looked it up on his PC. How did he look
it How did she look it up on his PC? It
wasn't shared with anybody. It was
shared with uh Destiny in like 2019. He
would have had years of logs between
that with Pixie, right? Where did he
look? Where did she look it up? Where
was that video sitting that apparently
Abby found it within seconds on his PC?
I I'm literally I can grant you this
insane assertion that she went through
his PC or all of his Discord messages or
something and you still can't explain
this because you're a [__] and you
believe everything he tells you without
any actual intellectual curiosity or any
internal monologue or any ability to
discern fact from fiction.
Sad. Sad. Point and laugh at Luxer Q. He
is sad.
Anyway, what's the what's the next
thing?
What's the next thing? We go back to
this video. Yeah. So, he just made up.
He just says, "Oh, she she said that she
looked through his whole computer and uh
Oh, and also there's like evidence of
this.
>> I might have gone through his entire
computer and there might be like
photographic evidence of me doing that
when I was at his house." Like, you
know, that
>> we just looked at the photographic
evidence apparently.
Like if this does go if it were to go to
trial, like imagine that person on the
witness stand, right? So you've given
like three different testimonies about
what it is that you even saw or was sent
here because initially she said like she
saw videos of like me and these these
three testimonies. She says in here that
it's a black video. She might have had
it maybe it was saved as like an MP4
file but it was just the audio or
something, right? Like we have no idea
on that front at all. But that's not
really like I don't need that to be like
totally accurate or that it's a video of
this person. I don't know how it's even
I don't even know how this is like a um
like a talking point. She's referencing
things that she should have no idea
exists.
>> These videos don't even exist. I've
never known these at all. But she can be
like, "Well, I misspoke there." And I
was like, "Okay, well in your
declaration you said that he sent you
these things." It's like, "Okay, yeah."
And it's like where?
>> Yes. Okay. So So three different things,
three things that are incompatible that
she received videos of Cherry. Okay,
that's maybe that's maybe okay. Maybe.
Also, she said she testified that you
sent her these things. That's apparently
an incompatible statement. How
>> were you or were you not in his
apartment um taking pictures of
>> Oh. Oh, he's going to pretend to be the
lawyer. Hold on. Let's see how he walks
this down in terms of questioning.
>> Were you or were you not in his
apartment um taking pictures of his
computer? It's like, well,
>> yes, I took a picture of his computer to
show that I was in his apartment. this
streamer, this famous streamer that I
just Yep. took a picture to show that I
was in his apartment. Yep.
>> Yeah. Is there a chance you saw stuff
then? I don't know.
>> No, I don't know. No, I don't recall
seeing anything then. What do you mean
when you texted Darius? Major leaks
incoming. Well,
>> oh, so she texted that to Darius and
Darius has additional texts here. So,
why don't we just ask Darius what Major
Leaks probs means, right? What did you
mean when when she texted Major League
P? If if she meant I'm going to leak
things off of his computer instead of
just I'm leaking his screen right now,
why don't we just get those additional
texts from Darius?
Can someone explain that to me why we
wouldn't just get those additional texts
from Darius showing all this malfeasants
or something?
Can anybody explain that to me?
I would just love to
like you have to you have to literally
suck this guy off to be anywhere near
right at all trying to believe this
stuff then I don't know what do you mean
when you texted Darius major leaks
incoming well I was just joking
and then I can produce both
>> well I was just joking I would just say
did she leak things
you can you can know what her intent was
you just see what she did
>> both of our logs on my side So there's
like it's like this is like it's
>> dude dude dude you can see both of our
logs on my side because what if you
deleted your logs? What do you mean? If
I delete all my logs with somebody and
go actually I have both of our logs
downloaded and they only have one side.
Doesn't that mean they're just Can't we
say that they're untrustworthy? Guys,
no. What?
Guys, I deleted I deleted all the logs
on my side and now I have I have
retained copies of both. I can show both
sides. Can they? No.
Darius, major leaks incoming. Well, I
was just joking.
And then I can produce both of our logs
on my side. So there's like it's like
this is like it's they know that it's he
he he realized halfway through that.
Okay. Halfway through that he realized
he wasn't cooking at all. that he was
saying something totally nonsensical he
had no point to make and he's a complete
[__] and so he just goes so anyway so
to suffice to say
>> our logs on my side so there's like it's
like this is like it's they know that
it's like you just slow down and listen
to this guy and you actually just hear
that he he's not even thinking in a
straight line. He's totally
disregulated. He's totally disabled.
He's not thinking in a straight line at
all. Right.
So it's not.
>> So you can just tell it's all
So you can basically just tell it's all
>> here. I'll let it I'll play it the whole
way through. We'll just we'll just
listen to him the whole way.
>> It is that you even saw or was sent here
because like trial like that right now.
>> And also I might have computer and there
might be like photographic evidence of
me doing that when I was at his house.
Like you know that on like if this does
go if it were to go to trial
>> from if it were to go to trial guys this
is how it would go. Imagine that person
on the witness stand. Right. So, you've
given like three different testimonies
about what it is that you even saw or
was sent to because initially she
>> No, actually the testimony I've given is
all compatible with itself.
>> A video file that had a black screen and
that's why it would be audio. By the
way, Destiny very obviously obviously
repeatedly saying he recorded audio just
to be clear.
>> He said like she saw videos of like me
and Cherry Fighting. These these videos
don't even exist. I've never done these
at all. But she can be like, "Well, I
misspoke there." And I was like, "Okay,
well, in your declaration, you said that
he sent you these things." It's like,
"Okay, yeah." And it's like,
>> she said she was sent that stuff, but if
it was a audio, would that not still
apply?
>> Were you were you not in his apartment
um taking pictures of his computer? It's
like, well, yeah. Is there
>> So, you you said you were sent videos
and later clarified that it was of a
black screen and you were in his
apartment. This proves that you are
lying.
>> Chance you saw stuff then? I don't know.
What do you mean when you texted Darius
major leaks incoming? Well, I was just
joking
and then I can produce both of our logs
on my side.
>> Oh, and he can and he because he deleted
his side of the logs and archive first,
he can produce both sides of the logs.
These things together, the testimonies
that aren't three different testimonies
and don't don't cut each other off at
all. Okay, the picture and the texts and
the fact that he deleted his own logs
and could produce both sides prove that
everything's totally made up. But it
doesn't answer the question of, "Hey
Destiny, how in 2024, sorry, in 2023, is
Abby aware of a Pixie video that later
becomes public that you said you haven't
sent to anybody else?" How? You could
say it's through your computer, then how
where was it on your computer? How? How?
And were you sending a bunch of videos
to this Abbeby person? So there's like
it's like this is like it's they know
that it's f there's any evidence of her
spying on your computer. It's got to be
in those Darius texts, right? Wouldn't
it just be in those Darius texts?
Could we just can we just go?
He can provide both sides of the logs.
Can he show that they were never sent? I
assume so.
>> Isn't that said? So it's not I I believe
Abby or sorry I believe Ellie B asked
him about this. just to the stress. It's
not like an accident and it's not um
it's not them like making mistakes. It's
they're intentionally like playing game.
It's they're just using the court to do
the PR stuff basically.
>> So he he's saying court is for PR here.
Okay, that will be interesting. I'll
address that in just a second, but I
just want to make it clear. He's saying
Aby's clearly lying. Her testimony has
been in uh inconsistent. All the
testimony has been 100% consistent with
all of the evidence provided by Abby.
Okay. The the only thing they cast out
in this is her sitting in front of that
computer. All I would say is just let
Darius leak the rest of the texts. Do
you have the Darius text so we can
revisit exactly what she told them? Are
there are the Darius texts out there?
Where are the rest did Darius leaked
more of his texts with her? Not the
Discord logs, but did Darius leak more
of that text conversation? Cuz I would
just love to know what else is in there
that apparently they're leaks. Cuz
here's the thing. If Abby like told
Darius like, "Oh, I went through his
computer and I found like a video of
Pixie." And and I would want that just
to be out there. I don't want I don't
want this guy I don't want this guy to
like I don't want people to make things
up about this guy and then he goes to he
gets sued or something or he loses in
court. I want him to be I want him to
lose in court because of the truth,
right?
I don't need I don't want anything to be
made up about him or him to get totally
wrapped in court.
So Aby's testimony is not consistent.
And you have to answer the question of
how she's aware of the pixie thing in
2023. If in September, okay, here's the
other thing. If it's in September, she
sees these September 5th, why does she
wait 2 months to mention it to anybody?
Can somebody explain that one to me,
too? She apparently waits two months to
mention it to anyone,
but you're arguing that she's going to
leak stuff.
Very strange. Very strange stuff. I the
inconsistencies pile up.
>> Anyway, back to this. Oh god, he just
said, "Dude, I
>> He lies so densely. I can't even get
through the vod."
>> It's not just to stress. It's not like
an accident and it's not um
>> It's not them like making mistakes. It's
They're intentionally like playing
games. It's They're just using the court
to do the
>> Has Abby proven her allegations? Uh yes.
She's literally proven them to us in the
filings. But you're too engage today,
Alexa. So, you're going to go for a
little bit. Bye-bye. Just go look at the
filing. She's shown evidence of the
things she said. Unless you think for
some reason she doesn't have her text
messages with Destiny on her side.
The only thing that we haven't seen is
her all of her logs from Destiny's side
or from her side, right? But
consequentially consequently, we could
also just say, well, Destiny should
provide all of his logs. No. Why doesn't
he just show us exactly what was sent or
exactly what happened here? Cuz
realistically, without his side of it,
it's just going to be Abby saying
things. There's no reason to believe it
would be positive or dispositive of
anything else said with just her side of
the logs.
Anyway,
>> uh PR stuff basically.
>> Oh, Pixie just running PR stuff against
him. That seems insane to me, right?
Pixie clearly has valued her privacy,
wants her privacy respected through this
whole thing. That's like been her number
one thing. She wants her privacy
respected, right? That's literally she's
filing this case because her privacy was
disrespected.
And not only that, Destiny literally
hired the PR lawyer. He hired the lawyer
who costs double what other good lawyers
cost because he wants to run his own PR
campaign.
Destiny is leaking everything except the
evidence that would exonerate him.
Right. He'll leak anything. He'll leak
anything to denigrate anybody, but he
will not he will not release evidence
exonerating him.
Shocking. Absolutely shocking.
Destiny doesn't want to produce any logs
that exonerate him. He likes spending
money on lawyers and keeping the case
going.
He likes putting Andy Bee's kids through
college. Okay? He likes buying a new
Lambo for Andy B. He literally got the
most expensive lawyer in this field who
exclusively makes sure that your PR is
spared. He has said precisely. He has
said precisely, I don't care if I lose
this. I can't lose in the court of
public opinion. That's more important. I
don't care about losing in court. I
don't want to lose in the court of
public opinion. He has said this
verbatim.
And now he's complaining about Pixie
doing a PR thing.
You can the United States help pay off
the national debt. Beed based based.
Is there any downside for them doing
this? Um, theoretically the downside is
court cost and reputation. Uh, Pixie has
no reputation and I think that they're
working pro bono a family. Wait, what
was that? Is there any downside for them
doing this?
Is there any downside? Uh, publicizing
the case. Um, spending a bunch of money
on lawyers. Yeah, there's a bunch of
downsides. All of the harass all the
online harassment she's getting.
Basically, a ton of her fan base are
people who are fans of Destiny first and
her second, right? She's basically
saying, "Okay, well, the whole
influencing thing I was kind of working
on, I'm willing to throw that away."
Right? There are a bunch of downsides
for her. Are they as steep as Steven's
downsides? Maybe not.
Um, theoretically, the downside is court
cost and reputation. Uh, Pixie has no
reputation. And
>> she absolutely has a reputation that
you've been sullying all over the
internet. The are you saying?
>> I think that they're working pro bono.
W's a family friend is my guess.
>> Working pro bono. Evidence. Evidence.
keep she he keeps saying Joan Schlump
Peters is a family friend. Evidence, any
evidence, anything showing this? Any
reason to believe this? Anything? Any
anything and literally any evidence
would be nice. So,
he's saying Joan's a family friend. He
said that the whole time.
Do you think that their goal is to just
survive to trial and hope a jury
sympathizes with Pixie more than they
might be swayed by the emotional like
not to sound like an but the problem is
that the real world is not like oh this
guy who's also tweeting about doing
secret recordings and tweeting about
doing secret recordings tweeting about
kids like dead kids not to be an
guys I know I just tweeted about how
funny it was that those Texas kids died
but like not to be an to be an guys
Um, this sounds so mean to say. I don't
mean to be mean like this, but the real
world is is not the same as the online
world. Like, in the real world,
>> tell me more about the real world,
Destiny. Tell me more about the real
world, Destiny. I This is who I come to
for my takes about the real world. The
guy who looks like he has muscular
distrophe. 100%. Real world takes coming
in from Destiny right now. I honestly
doubt he's able to lift these rifles
at fault. Like women are hardcore shamed
still in the real world. Like a jury is
probably going to be more sympathetic to
me than they are to her. I know
everybody has this fantasy in
>> you think so this guy is a blah blah but
they're not going to see that.
>> They're not going to see that. I advise
Destiny to show up to court. Okay.
Because the the defender aura coming off
of you with this haircut and goatee is
astronomical. Okay. They can detect this
from Mars. Your defender aura is crazy
with this comb over. Okay. Do you think
we can't recognize the haircut, bro?
Just cuz you got a goatee instead of the
little pencil mustache. We recognize the
haircut. I don't know why you thought
this was a good look. I don't know why
you thought this was a good idea. All
right. But you look you look
disconcerting. The average person when
they look at you, they get like an
uncanny valley feeling. The jury will
absolutely feel that. I'm very excited
for this to go to trial. Okay.
I'm very excited. They're going to see,
oh, there's a girl who recorded videos
with a guy where she sent videos of her
and her boyfriend to this guy and he
sent videos of him and his wife to this
girl and you know they've been doing all
this trading around
trading around. No, not trading around.
Hold on, dude. From the very beginning,
this has been the story. I
pixie shared with her boyfriend. You
said I believe Destiny said this. I tell
girls that Molina has access to my
stuff. So like she'll probably see
anything that gets sent to me. He said
this himself.
That doesn't mean you have because you
say, "Oh, my wife has access to my
stuff, so she might see this." That
doesn't mean you have you have license
to share it to whoever you want. Just
like Pixie when she tells you she's
doing this because her boyfriend's like
into it or whatever the right doesn't
mean you have access opportunity to
share it with whoever. That doesn't make
any sense.
And then she was sort of like you really
think a juryy's going to stand up like
oh my god this is like horrible like
that that's a this is like an online
position of like everybody is a a
yasider most
what what
then she like you really think a juryy's
going to say like oh my god this is like
horrible like that that's a this is like
an online position of like everybody is
a a yaslider most people especially like
older people geners and and older are
going to look at it and be like oh wow
these are some horny stupid kids. These
are some crazy wacky kids doing.
>> No, that's not it's not going to look
like that. And by the way, what they're
also going to do is you're going to take
all the tweets where you're making fun
of Pixie yourself or making fun of Pixie
saying you like record things secretly.
They're going to look at all of these
tweets. They're going to look at her
crying and they're going to look at you
looking like a not actually a just
looking like a and they're going to
sympathize with her. Obviously, you're
barely human. And most people will be
able to pick that up from you
immediately that you are barely human.
doing some stupid.
[Music]
These are just some crazy kids doing
some crazy.
He said kids. He is sounding like one.
Yeah, dude. His his that's that's
actually breaking his chat. Kids unc
pushing 40. Mind you, that's that's bad
enough when he refers to himself as a
kid that his own chat's going to go,
"Yo, I get, dude, I believe you on
everything else. You're totally being
persecuted here." But like, don't refer
to yourself as a kid, okay? With that
haircut and that goat teeth. Do not do
not refer to yourself as a kid.
How can you ever go to trial in federal
court when the subject matter
jurisdiction isn't even there? Well,
they're trying to Abby lets them push
the subject matter jurisdiction issue by
saying that we have somebody. It's not
just Abby that lets them push the
subject matter jurisdiction issue,
right? Subject matter uh sorry, subject
matter uh what is it? If you file for
summary judgement,
basically there have to be no FA facts
at in contention anymore. There
obviously are facts in contention,
right? The question his chat asks are so
funny. They're obviously the bi obvious
with the bias. Yes.
But I don't think that's the only thing
that pushes it. There's still like a
factual dispute that might have to be
argued before a jury about the time
stamps. Now, I personally think that's
insane. I personally think it's obvious
that the time stamps are when they are.
Okay. But there's also what is there?
There's one other thing. There's the
idea of continuous publishing that might
have to be heard in front of a judge
with all the relevant facts presented,
right, with arguments. So, like those
aren't the only things that that keep
this case going. There are still many
facts in dispute here. Somebody who's
willing to testify that um he sent her a
video in 2023 or whatever. That's the
that's her testimony.
Now, how is a judge? The the question
will come down to
>> her testimony is I he sent me a video in
2023. I don't have the logs of him
sending me the video, but I do have the
logs of me describing the video at
question in this trial to people in 2023
after he sent it to me. So, that is the
best I can do. But that's I hope enough
for you guys to consider like letting
this case go to trial or I hope that's
like I hope this is valuable to you. um
for a summary judgement. The question
will come down to whether or not a judge
looks at that and says there is an
actual factual material dispute. There's
a material dispute in fact that and that
technically can only be resolved in
front of a jury um or judge if it's a
bench or a judge trial. But but I don't
know how conservative or how
um
liberal not like in a political sense
like judges look at evidence like that.
that alleged transmission to Abby wasn't
connected to the leaks that resulted on
Kiwi Farms, right? Um, correct?
>> No.
Yeah. And then there's the whole
question of even like damages because
um,
Destiny, how can this case go to trial
when all these people are lying about
you?
How does how does a judge not dismiss
this out of hand? It's so clear. They're
all working against you. Destiny,
Destiny, Destiny, Destiny, please tell
me how how come you haven't filed your
counter suits yet, Destiny. They're all
working against you. It's a conspiracy.
They're defaming you. Destiny, why
aren't your counter suits firing off
already?
I can't I need I want to read the
transcript. When they go over at the end
of the um hearing when they when the
because they're trying to argue for why
they also have the cyber harassment
thing included and then the judge is
arguing with them about foreseeability
and the judge is like well how is it
that you can say this person did this
with like malicious intent and like well
anytime you send a video like that you
have to accept that it could end up
online.
That would be a really stupid argument.
I don't know why her lawyers would have
made that argument. That's obviously a
argument. And then the judge is like,
"Isn't that exactly what your client
did?" And they're like, "Well,
there's no way." So that is true. That
would be really bad. If Pixie's lawyers
just stopped arguing there, that would
be very very very embarrassing. No,
because realistically, the next question
is, and it's it's like, okay, so she
sent it to her boyfriend, her long-term
boyfriend, her only partner, only other
partner, right? with your permission and
you shared it with your wife or had it
in somewhere where your wife could see
it with her permission.
How did you know that you could trust
this other person? Right. What made you
trust this other person? Destiny, could
you describe what made you trust this
other person?
Oh, well, that's interesting. Well, can
we can we talk about like why you
decided to share a bunch of these things
with a like a 19-year-old that you
didn't age verify that you admit in your
own DMs you didn't age verify could have
been under 18 that you actually in DMs
to people were very concerned that they
were under 18 and how that would be the
thing that would majorly sink you out of
this entire drama. Right? How did you
come to trust them that this wouldn't be
sent? Right? Cuz he's arguing about
foreseeability.
Correct. Well, the foreseeability thing
on just sending a video, that would be
stupid. But what about sending a video
to an 18-year-old, 17 or 18year-old or
19year-old who you've never met in real
life, had never had a conversation with,
right? Had never had a like a phone call
conversation with. What What about the
foreseeability of sending it to that
person who you have no you haven't even
verified their identity? For all you
know, they could be catfishing you.
What's the foreseeability then?
But apparently everybody's like, "Oh,
they would have just stopped asking
questions at this time."
I said 17, 18, 19. I've I also went out
of my way to highlight how she was very
possibly underage.
>> Well, yeah, but it's different because
um
>> he himself said to me directly, "Man,
I'm really scared that she might be
underage cuz that's the only thing
that'll sink me here. I can sweep the
rest of it away. I can sweep the rest of
it away, but if she's under if she's
under 18, I can't sweep that away
>> because well, you know, she there was
consent there or whatever. It's like
what what is the difference here? Like
even if even if it was non-conentual
like isn't like foreseeability is what
we're talking about, right? So that
would mean that sending anything because
the the Oh my god. Yeah. Foreseeability
for the foreseeability of sending it to
a a child, a person who you couldn't get
to fly out of your place because their
parents wouldn't let them, right? Is
that not correct, Destiny? Would that
not have been concerning to you that
when you asked her to meet you in real
life, she said, "My parents won't let me
fly to you." Was that concerning to you?
Or did you think that that wasn't a big
deal?
Hm.
>> Her lawyers are so cr um her lawyers are
so cringe.
I feel like they when they they it felt
like they thought they were in a TV show
and they're like asking me these
questions like they have like these
killer gotchas and they're like the
dumbest gotchas in the world. was like,
"Bro, I don't remember how much of this
I talked about, but he's like, "You
testified today that you actually didn't
have your law firm contact Kiwi Farm.
So, did you lie earlier when you said
that you did?" And I'm like, "I had my
assistant contact them. My assistant is
not my lawyer." And then every time they
would get like shut down in a line of
questioning the
Okay, who hears these like little
tidbits of testimony is like, "Oh, Dusty
totally crushed it. Dashy it."
judge like picks his papers up and he
like shuffles them. I can tell that he's
like aborted a whole lot of questioning.
Ah, because the judge shuffled papers.
Okay.
Wow.
Given that Jane also sent your videos
without your consent, do you not have a
good chance of winning even if
hypothetically you sent videos after the
party date? Like, does that be even
matter beyond keeping the guest alive?
Um, even if the Abby stuff was true,
which it's not, but
>> I don't I don't think has he outright
stated she didn't have his consent or
something because I believe that's not
true at all.
>> Even if it was, there are still like a
bunch of other issues that you would
even have to fight to to get
>> Oh, I didn't even listen to that
question. Given that Jane also sent your
videos without your consent, do you not
have a good chance of winning even if
hypothetically you sent videos after the
party date? Like does Abby even matter
beyond keeping the guest alive? Um, even
if the Abby stuff was true, which it's
not, but even if it was, there are still
like a bunch of other issues that you
would even have to fight to to get to a
win, let alone damages. Um, but it's um
technically
[Music]
I don't I'm trying to think of
>> everybody here, everybody in this chat
obviously is just under a total framing
of like Destiny's the complete victim
here. Destiny is the total victim.
>> Actually, I don't even know how that
would work. Like let's say some law was
passed in 2024 that said you can't say
you to somebody and let's say somebody
says you in 2023 and then someone like
well you could you sue the the second
person. I'm actually I don't know how
that works. I'm not sure.
Okay. The
>> from the profile leaks got you.
>> I hope there is an unclean hands defense
on the basis of her sending your videos.
Okay. I don't like that this meme gets
passed around so much because people
keep saying this. People keep saying
this thing. It's like, okay, well,
Destiny might have done a bad thing, but
she did a bad thing, too. No, that means
that nobody did a bad thing.
No, it doesn't. Like, people say two
wrongs don't make a right, but in some
circumstances, they kind of do. For
instance, if one side is being accused
of a party and then it turns out,
actually, no, the other side wanted to
rape the other person. That doesn't mean
that two people raped each other. That
just means they had, right?
Huh?
Okay, hold on, hold on, hold on. But
that's not the thing here. Like, what if
we just said I I I stole $300 from
somebody and they stole $300 from me.
Well, that means no crime was committed.
No, that does mean two crimes were
committed. What are we talking about?
It's not okay to steal from somebody so
long as they stole from you.
What?
Also, the idea of like a would be like
you doing a an act together in the same
room.
These these weren't acts done together
in the same room. Let's see how DG
responds to that totally idiotic
hypothetical.
It cancels out. He's right. They kind of
do. He's right. So, like if there's an
agreement or discussion before each
other,
>> two wrongs make a right. Mhm. Oh, this
guy's I think they
So like if there's an agreement or
discussion beforehand about like you
know who do we send these videos to what
is the policy around this and then there
was agreement and then an understanding
at least there right this is this is
just sad it's sad to like not understand
>> it doesn't mean like oh I guess both
sides violate agreements oh the
agreement was probably not what this one
person who's lied about like 20
different things has presented it as you
know
>> who lied about 20 different things did
they really they really lie about 20
different things.
Okay. All right. All right. Wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait. I wanted to pull
something up for this. Let me find it.
Let me find it. Lying about 20 different
things. Let me check it out. I think I
have I think I have a little link for
this. Let me start looking through some
of his statements because it's just like
crazy how he um how he does some of
these things. I think it's these logs
where he talks about the Pixie thing,
right? Is this the logs? Oh, yeah. I
think she gave three different answers.
So, he just talks about this is the
pixie thing, right? Okay, hold on. But
let's read from the bottom. Oh, he talks
he basically throws Kylo under the bus,
too. I didn't even see this from before.
Oh my goodness,
dude. Gravitas. Kylo is being
in this and she shouldn't have been
talking about this at all. Lol W. So,
already throws Kylo under the bus, says
she shouldn't have been talking about it
at all. Um, we'll see. Maybe we'll check
the Kylo video after this. It's just
hard explaining to non-gooners what the
Goonar lifestyle is. Uh-huh. The Gooner
lifestyle. So, listen. I want you to
imagine that you have like a a label
that gets applied to you, right? Like
consent violator. Okay? What's the best
way to deal with a label like consent
violator? It's to rebrand, right? Oh, I
don't like that word. Consent violator.
What? No. No. I'm not a consent
violator. I have a gooner lifestyle,
guys. I don't I don't just like
habitually violate consent. I have a
gooner lifestyle. Uh-huh. This is as
transparent to everybody who has any
amount of free will or or intelligence
or co uh or cognition. Okay? Everybody
understands that this is the exact same
as rebranding to maps. Okay? We're not
going to let that happen. You are not
going to remap. You're not going to
rebrand the map. In this case, you
cannot take your habitual consent
violations and rebrand to a gooner
lifestyle. Yourself, okay?
You can't do it. You are a consent
violator. That is not that has nothing
to do with being a gooner. Okay? And
he's so lucky that a lot of these other
things probably can't really be used by
the jury against him. Right? The fact
that he violated Molina's consent, the
fact that he violated Saj's consent, the
fact that he violated Aby's consent, the
fact that he violated Cher's consent,
the fact that he's violated these
people's consent. Okay, there are more,
but I can't I'm just off the top of my
head, I'm not ringing them all out, but
those can't be used to prove that he did
this crime. But to call it a good
lifestyle when so many people have come
out and said you shared these things
non-consensually, like nobody's
confused. Nobody who's paying attention
or isn't just a part of your weird your
weirdo freak community, okay? Everyone
else understands what's going on. We all
see it.
You can't You can't get away from the
consent violations. We all see what you
are, right? He's sully in Gunnar's good
name. Well, he's just making it seem
like, "Oh, guys, I was just like, off,
guys. They caught me. They caught me. I
was just being inappropriately." No,
you're violating people's consent
repeatedly over and over and over again
after being asked not to. Nicely. God,
where is the Bob? I always have this Bob
7 clip. Dude, he was literally asked not
to. Hey, don't do that. Here, one
second. Let's just play. I'll be right
back.
>> So, a long time ago. Okay. So, a long
time ago. So, sometimes, so obviously,
okay, me and Lena send nudes to people.
Um, me and had a conversation about
there were a few girls we talked to. I
was like, "Oh, cool. Like, we should
record videos of like us going to send
to people. Like, it's fun." So, we do
this. Um, I kind of like have like my
little archive of like material that
I'll send to people if I want to. Um,
there were girls that I talked to um
past that that I'd send stuff of like
either me or me and Molina. and Molina
talked to me and she was like, "Hey, um
if you're going to send any videos to um
new girls that we haven't talked about,
like let me know that first." Um because
she wanted to be careful. And I was
like, "Okay, sure." That was fine. I
didn't think of it at the time cuz I
didn't think it mattered, but um yeah,
sure. So, I thought about that. So, that
was like an issue that me and Molina had
that we talked about and then we
resolved, right? the way that the way
that
>> Okay, so this isn't even the first time
he's had this exact thing spelled out
for him directly.
Directly. This is why every single [__]
who says, "Guys, he's not going to do it
again. He got caught. He knows it's bad.
It's been explained to him. Now he's
like he's been penalizing. He's never
going to do it again.
This is already like the third or fourth
time it's been it's happened. This is
the third or fourth time he's had to
have this lesson taught to him. Why? Why
the would you think he'd learn his
lesson?
By the way, he said Bob 7 screen sharing
nudes, right? It's like career ending
allegations.
Life ending allegations.
Jury will love this clip too, dude. And
one of the people who said he was
sharing things non-conensually this time
is the person whose consent he violated
here, right? He literally tried to make
the Gooner culture, the Goonar culture
argument back here during the Bob 7 arc.
This should have been the only time this
was applicable. Okay. You cannot forgive
this a second time. All right.
You can't.
Lauren Southern is the only woman he
protected. Uh tried to. Yeah.
Her son on the other hand, that kid's
identity is just up for grabs thanks to
him.
Okay. All right. We continue on with
whatever this is. Eventually, he gets
onto some skitso mind map, so that'll be
fun. Okay. He does he does state of play
for the completely mentally
[Music]
Check desks. I don't want to check your
DMs, Radiant, because I hate you. You're
fired.
I actually hired um Cyber is now doing
my new stuff. And Radiant is fired. I
have 450 Hassan posts ready to go, boy.
Yeah, boy. Yeah, boy.
Cool.
What would you do if they drop the case,
but the hearing stays sealed? It seems
like the hearing being sealed would mean
a good amount of reputation. No, that
can't possibly be they can't do that. No
way.
I don't think they're dropping the case.
I don't see why they would drop the
case.
>> I think that here's what
if
>> Dude, that transcript I don't think that
transcript means anywhere near as much
as he thinks it does. I have no I have
no way to know for sure, but he's like
hinging everything on this transcript
for a procedural hearing for a motion to
grant a preliminary injunction to get
him to stop leaking more pixie sex and
for a couple other things that they
should never have asked for, right? Like
it's not really actually material to the
case. It's like saying he's an it's like
a it's a hearing on why he's an he
thinks it's going to be like super
material to the case. If they if that
happened, then what I would do is I
would go to the deep jungles of Brazil
and I would take Iawaska and I would
convene with the gods. And while
convening with the gods, I would sit
down
>> with pen and parchment and I would try
my best to recall every single word that
was said. Exactly.
You literally bought and received the
transcript and told all of us about it.
You literally said in DGlo logs, you
bought and received the full transcript.
What is the purpose of this?
I don't I don't even know what the
purpose of this would be. You literally
told everybody you bought and received
the transcript already. It was just the
seal that's preventing you from
releasing it
>> during that hearing. And then I would
read my recollection on stream. That's
what I would do. Okay.
>> Uh-huh.
You literally have the full transcript.
You told us about it.
Is there anything in motion right now
for counter suing dope or Abby? No.
Although I don't know. He's more or less
said what's in the transcript. No, he
talks about it constantly.
>> Um
>> Oh, is there any recourse for sewing
suing Doe or Abby? So, Abby or um or
Pixie.
I don't I don't know what the validity
any case there would even be or what
that the problem is that like my like
the problem is that I have a real law
firm that likes to win cases. So if I
just want to do some dexious litigation,
I'm like can we just Oh, hold on, hold
on, hold on. I actually missed I forgot
we were going over this and then I hit
play on the video to be right back. We
kept going. I went I went way past this
guys. Also, he said Pixie lied 20 times
and I forgot to go through the rest of
this. Whoops. There's a lot of other
good stuff in here cuz he continues to
comment on the Kyla with the Turkey Tom
interview. I think Kyla asked me
something like, "Did you explicitly ask
her if you could send this video to some
girl?" And I said, "No, it didn't really
work that way." That's not what Kyla
What did Kyla say about it? Do we have
the Hold on. Turkey Tom not so aerodite.
Hold on. We We'll just see.
>> Leaked them to Sunday. I think Becket,
>> it's somewhere right around here.
>> What do you think about this? This is
what Kyla was suggesting. And Aaron was
saying like, I think she's being sneaky.
And Pixie was being like, I don't think
she was being she's being sneaky. Um,
like early December when I went, "Did
she know you're recording and did she
consent to it?"
Um he said that she did know about the
recording. Like she's aware she did
consented to the actual filming of it,
>> but that he said specifically probably
not. Um like it was 3 years ago. I don't
remember specifically and like things
were open like this, but yeah, probably
not. I didn't get like explicit consent.
And I said, Stephen, that's really
[__] up. Like that's not okay. Um, and
so just to be clear, he'd probably he
would say, "I didn't
>> bad Stephen. Bad bad dog." No. No. No.
Do that was bad.
Now I'm going to love you forever and
never bring this up in your in your
presence ever again. Okay. But bad bad
dog.
Cool.
Okay. So, did you explicitly ask her if
you could send it to the video to some
girl? I said, "No, it didn't really work
that way." So, it was an explicit
consent to send the video. I don't know
about to some girl, but send the video,
I guess. Didn't really work that way. I
don't remember for sure, but no,
probably not was what he said. Okay.
This was a Never mind. But like during
the the hearing, Pixie told the judge
that she sent all of our videos to her
ex-boyfriend, and I didn't even know
that. lol W. Then why did she when when
basically Pixie asks like, "Oh, who
could possibly know about us having
sex?" Pixie is the one who says,
"Obviously my boyfriend would know,
right? That was the whole arrangement
that I got permission to you." Like
that's that's the whole thing.
Anyway, but that was kind of what she
what we said when we recorded stuff.
Just don't leak it. Lol. Basically,
okay.
So, like only with your like exact
stable partner right now. Don't let it
like don't send it to people. Maybe if
you want to show them on your phone or
something. Okay. Like no girl has ever
damned me in my life and asked if they
could share any specific video we've
recorded with anyone else else ever
because that's just not usually how it
works. But some girl aka your wife has
told you, "Hey, you're sharing that
without my consent. That's that's up.
Don't do that."
So why why is this even relevant? The
exact situation we're seeing here has
been pointed out to you as a up thing
and you agreed you had to stop it, that
it was wrong of you to do that, right?
Hey, I can't just send two new people
without asking that person, without
getting their consent.
Why is he pretending that this exact
this exact misunderstanding hasn't been
cleared up for him in the past?
Yes, Molina did this with pre Molina
literally got mad at him for not doing
it with pre-approved for doing it with
other girls after the ones she had
approved.
And then Molina had to find out when
these leaks came out that actually he
just kept doing it anyway. He just kept
sharing this stuff to randoms.
Okay.
Oh boy. Like okay. Uh Lin Woo. I mean I
wouldn't call them virgins. There's
probably somebody going, "Destiny,
aren't these people just virgins who
don't know how like sharing videos
works? Aren't they just virgins? Aren't
they just virgins? Destiny Lyn Woo. I
mean, I wouldn't call them virgins. It's
probably not normal, per se. It's just
annoying
to Listen, it was a Goonar culture.
Okay, I'm trying to do this remapping of
habitual consent violator, somebody with
no respect for I'm trying to remap that
onto Gooner culture, okay? Could you
please respect me?
Could you please respect me and my
gooner culture where I just share
people's nudes or videos without ever
asking if that's okay or ever getting
any form of consent at all?
Okay. Um, it's just annoying when I get
a huge spotlight of me and then people
think I'm engaged in some exceptionally
egregious behavior or something. You are
engaged in exceptionally egregious
behavior.
People People literally got mad at just
the Pixie DMs. You are engaged in actual
egregious behavior.
God cha. No clue. She's being insane
stupid manipulatable. It's hard to say.
This is about Pixie, right? And there's
some picture here. Do I want to go find
that picture really quickly? Give me a
second. Let me go find the picture here
real quick.
What?
Okay,
I look like that. Okay, here we go. Not
that one.
Uh, this one.
This one, I think. No longer available.
I can't even look at it, dude. Hold on.
Let me Let me see if this will work in
Discord. Sometimes this works. Oh, this
did work. Okay.
So, this is the this is the picture.
Happy birthday to the best girl I know
at Pixie Love on your actual birthday.
Pixie love at Lauren de Lagona.
Happy birthday, Pixie.
To which he says, like, it's so blatant.
Like it's so blatant.
What? Dude, the idea the fact that he
doesn't understand what like friendship
is and doesn't understand like human
companionship at all and like every
every instance of people just being
friends in a like platonic I don't need
to get something from you way is just
blatant evidence of a conspiracy against
him. Like he he actually it's he is the
robot in Westworld. He has no idea of
what this is, but it makes him
suspicious.
He can't fathom it. He actually can't
fathom it.
H Victor C26. I think she gave three
different answers in our hearing about
what the agreement was. Jesse, I think
she said once we agreed like don't send
it around. And then I think she said I
thought we he could send it to his wife.
And then I think she said I didn't tell
him he could send it to anyone. We
agreed like don't send it around. I
didn't tell him.
>> Where is Oh, hold on. Bacto, thank you
for the 15 months.
>> Where do any of these things contradict?
Is there a contradiction in any of those
three statements?
Can somebody point out the contradiction
in these three statements to me?
I thought he could send it to his wife.
I didn't tell him he could send it to
anyone. Those don't contradict. I
thought he could send it to his wife.
Okay.
What uh what is this link that you've
just sent me? Hold on. What it is? What
it is?
Oh, this one doesn't work either. This
content is no longer available. Hold on.
I have to put this in like a Discord
chat to open it. Oh, wait. He posted
again.
No way. No way. He posted it again, but
these are the logs this time. Okay, hold
on. Hold on. Where did I just I just
opened these. [__] Hold on. Right here.
I like that they even smile the same
now. Holy L W. And it's the same
picture. It's the same picture. It's the
same picture. I can't believe they even
smile the same now.
Dude, this guy's having like an actual
schizophrenic meltdown. It's so funny.
I like that they even have the same
smile now. Holy.
I think this smile is This is the smile
of a Kiwi farmer right here, guys.
Lauren and K Lauren and Pixie, they're
Kiwi farmers now. This is the smile of a
Kiwi farmer. What does that even mean?
Nobody knows what it means, but it's
provocative. Okay, nobody gets it.
Dude, how does this guy get off on
judging other people's mental health in
any way when these are the kinds of
things he's saying?
It's actually insane.
When he says he has offline friends, do
you actually believe him? Well, he might
just be hearing voices at this point.
Like, it's a there's a decent chance
he's just hearing voices in his head.
Okay.
I think, dude,
I
h it's just it's wild. It's wild. And I
stopped following it. I stopped
following it for a little while because
I was going to like I was just moving
away from it, right? And he just keeps
wanting to drag me back in. He just
wants to keep talking about me or my
Discord. I want to move away from it. I
want to go into drama stuff. I want to
talk about TAP and TAP getting hacked.
And this guy can't stop talking about
me.
I think Destiny's actually mentally
broken because of what happened. It
seems that way.
Got to wonder what kind of dude takes
videos of himself sucking off strangers.
That is a excellent question.
Do you have the text of Pixie? I don't
know if there are texts like that,
Skumi.
I do think Destiny, one of the first
things he said was, "Well, obviously we
could have shared it shared it with
somebody cuz I said obviously, you know,
my wife has access to stuff. She She'll
probably see something, right?
Oh, a gay dude. Dude, that was funny.
That was like um That was Ardite and
Nick. That was their response to like
the secret pocket recordings. That was
their response was I think that's just a
part of gay culture, guys. You just like
secretly record [__] [__]
because that's a part of gay culture.
Your grinder hookups, you can totally
you can totally record those, you know,
without consent because that is just gay
culture. Of
course he's mindbroken. He aggressively
platformed you hoping that you wouldn't
become Basheran.
H
dude. God. Where? I knew this was going
to take forever to get through. I tried
watching this. I was trying to
pre-screen a little bit of this before
the stream and I was like, "Dude, I have
to pause every 30 seconds. I have to
pause every 5 seconds because he just
says so many things." And then I have to
go back and play it again so you guys
can get all the connecting context.
Anyway, anyway, anyway, anyway, we're
back to the video. I'll pull it back
about 20 seconds so we can see where we
are. I'm getting water for Abby. No,
although I don't know if
um
I don't I don't know what the validity
of any case there would even be or what
that the problem is that like my like
the problem is that I have a real law
firm that likes to win cases. So if I
just want to do some dexious litigation,
I'm like can we just see these the uh
hold on hold on hold on hold on hold on
we're about to get there. Okay, let me
open up the uh under your skin album. We
need the under under your skin under
your skin album. Is it under your skin?
Is that what it's called? Oh, that's not
what it's called. What is it? Oh, what
are these songs from? Kiss. Oh, [__]
What is the What is the skitso? Under
the skin. Under the skin. Yes, under the
skin. Cuz we're about to enter the
actual skitso zone. Okay. We're about to
get there. Uh soundtrack.
Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes.
think they would go for it just for the
memes, right? That's like more memey.
>> He's about to open up paint.
>> Doesn't the judge need to order it
dismissed? They can't decide that on
their own. No, you can dismiss your own
cases. For instance, when Tim P claimed
that he was going to sue Kla Harris and
Joe Biden for misquing a clip of his on
Twitter, uh, because he wanted all the
clout of saying he sued them for 600
bucks, he withdrew that case
voluntarily.
I don't know why you Yeah, I don't know
why you call that dismissing your own
case.
Withdrawing, better word.
Okay.
>> Have you seen the South Mar? I haven't
seen the episode. Um, but Pull up. Pull
up paint. It's right here. It's got to
be right here against Lauren. Um, I
mean, how I mean, she's the
>> How? She's been leading a conspiracy
against you. What do you mean how?
Shouldn't it be easy to prove that?
Don't you have proof of that? To make
that claim? She's literally leading a
conspiracy against you purely
maliciously to harm your reputation and
harm you personally because you rejected
her and you have evidence of this. Why
wouldn't you sue her?
There's a whole conversation that needs
to be had. Um,
>> I don't know.
>> A wobble combinator thing for the 10
months. Let's go.
>> There's like this is like a whole thing.
Me and D should have just talked about
this on anything else. We talked about
this off stream.
>> God, hold on.
>> Um, I've talked about this on stream a
lot.
>> I actually have to pause cuz I'm getting
a drink. Second,
[Music]
like actually getting a pop cuz I am
going to enjoy this. Okay, I'm getting a
pop. Got a Pepsi Zero Sugar here. Okay,
Pepsi Zero Sugar. My drink of choice to
really enjoy things. Okay, I realize I'm
like white trash. All right, I know. I
know. I know. I know.
We're just having a couple pops out
here. Okay. Unsubbed.
This is like Canadian culture. All
right. Just having a couple pops
with the boys. Having a couple pops. All
right. All right.
>> Let's go. Skitso mind map time.
>> Love to see it.
places like Kiwi Farms or um like I
don't even want to say snark subsidies
cuz they didn't exist back then. Um L
cow or PL or these aren't the only ones
I've ever heard.
>> Cherry I'm not making it up. Yes, Cherry
saw the supermarket signs. They say they
like people are going to anti and people
are going to hate and people are going
to be weird and you know it's fine. Like
you have I mean one you have a right to
do that.
>> Is it fine? Seems like it's not fine at
all. You know, if you want to talk [__]
>> Uh, are you concerned Destiny would be
doing a Dan and registering his streams
into the Library of Congress? No. I I'm
not an American citizen. I don't even
know if copyright law has any
jurisdiction over me. Right. I don't
have any American incorporation. I don't
know why American copyright law would
have any effect on me. You'd have to sue
me in Canada.
>> Yeah, that's fine. I don't think that's
necessarily
a problem.
>> Yes, they do. I think they have to sue
me under Canadian law. You can sue me,
but you have to sue me under Canadian
law. You shouldn't be able to sue me in
an American court. If I have no American
incorporation, I'm not American citizen.
>> I mean, obviously, as a public figure, I
don't want anybody to be mean to me
ever. But, you know, you don't have a
right to have nobody be mean about you.
The the thing that's happened recently,
and it's so weird because I'm trying to
think of this has only happened on the
left. I'm trying to think if this has
happened on the right. I I feel like it
must have. I'm just not as aware of it.
But the thing that's happened that is so
toxic has been the weaponization of
these. Like it's so funny, dude. He's
about to he's about to describe
weaponized like harassment and he talked
about this with Dan on anything else.
Can you guys think of someone who's like
weaponized harassment who's close to
Destiny?
Why? What?
like sub forums
and just the the basically I would call
it the open kind of um collaboration
with them.
The open collaboration this is not good.
Um this is not good. So what is the open
collaboration? Collaboration would be to
me planning, right? If you're going to
say that we're all public content
creators creating public content,
collaboration can't possibly be somebody
finding a link over here like a chatter
finding a link from one of these and
going somewhere else and going, "Hey,
you should check this out." That can't
be what collaboration is, right? Just
somebody saying like, "Here's a here's a
clip from Destiny's stream. You should
watch it." That can't be. There has to
be a higher bar for collaboration than,
"Oh, you saw a link or you saw a clip
that's somewhere and you put it
somewhere else."
This is why like my policy, by the way,
on all on all of these people. Now, I I
do not accept doxing or anything on any
of my platforms that I
>> So, I don't know why he's already
totally avowed doxing on every single
platform. I don't know why he's
pretending he hasn't. He's avowed the
doxing of me, of Queen, of whoever you
can get to, right? He's avowed this on
all of his platforms. I have a feeling
that somebody probably told him, "Hey,
you should uh you should not do that.
That's probably not smart where it's
against the terms of service." Um, and
that's it. I don't give a [__] about any
of this otherwise because these
>> He's saying only when it's against the
terms of service. Just to be clear, he
has no principled stance against doxing.
He did. He said it was the most one of
the most disgusting things you could do,
right? Months ago. Uh he absolutely had
a problem with doxing, but apparently
not anymore. It's just oh only if it's
against the toos. So in his chat or on
Twitter, he's like totally fine to try
to dox people. That's what he wants to
do. Will he going to be surely Willie
will stop posting in the Daliban
subreddit, right? Surely, surely,
surely.
I'm not even the only person from my
community he's like tried to dox or
amplify the doxes of, right? I find it
particularly egregious that he would
intentionally amplify the docs of Hutch
repeatedly and never let Hutch know that
it was out there, right?
That seems pretty crazy to me.
>> People are crazy. Um, that's the only
>> Does it count when you say it to Willie
Mack and then he posts it on to YouTube?
I think there's an argument for Destiny
where he has used the the constellation
of his platforms, his platforms as an
aggregate
to dox and make death threats. And that
if you look at him rather than each of
these individual platforms, it seems
insane to me that a platform would go,
you know what, we're not going to take
into account anything else here. Right?
That seems crazy to me. He's he's
absolutely weaponizing all of his
platforms to continue to make these
threats and continue to try and harass
people into not talking about him
anymore. He is at this point he is just
Keels except Keles like uh with a way
bigger audience and way more money,
right? Like trying to fight against Kiwi
Farms and all these other places
by by emulating Kiwi Farms, by the way.
Trying to fight against Kiwi Farms by
emulating Kiwi Farms.
Destiny was always okay with doxing. He
was always okay with doxing in like
certain situations. I think um I think
broadly like other content creators who
hadn't doxed you, he would he wouldn't
do that in the past.
>> Only reason why I don't do it because
the idea that um
so like like if you want to like I'm an
extreme example obviously, but like if
if you read my KB is actually hilarious.
These people are like actively involved
in stages of litigation where they try
to get like leaks or
>> actively involved in stages of
litigation where they try to get leaks.
Is he he's talking about his Kiwi Farms
thread or is he talking about Rakita's
Kiwi Farms thread? Cuz like Rakita,
they're like trying to get all kinds of
things on Rakita. I don't know what he's
talking about in his thread.
>> Pass stuff on to lawyers or they're like
trying to push certain narratives. Three
days ago.
>> Yeah, that's what Kiwi Farms is. They
they push narratives. They don't like
you and they push narratives.
>> So, I think in one page of my thread,
five different people who are close to
me got doxed for not being hard enough
against me. Like,
>> I don't know if that's true, but if it
were, that sucks. Doxing sucks.
>> Five different people in the span of 24
hours. Um, and it's like very we totally
like we totally disavow that. We do not
want doxers around us. We don't want
people doxed. I totally disavow that.
I've always disavowed that. So I banned
anybody who's bringing up the willy from
before. Right.
>> He's late, too. Like they don't like try
to hide it. They're just like
>> are the Oh, but yes. Sorry. Five people
close to him. Five people close to him.
Yes.
>> Okay.
>> Oh, like um I saw like Hutch.
>> Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait. Five people
close to him
>> said this thing.
>> Does anybody have his docs? Does anybody
dox him before? It'll be like super
blatant. And it also sucks cuz it's hard
to even talk about it cuz even just by
saying that in a way I've kind of sort
of like now passed along his docs, you
know?
>> Sure. It's hard to talk about it. The up
thing here is what he's going to allege
is that like I'm connected to Kiwi
Farms. Bro, Kiwi Farms has had never
never would have cared about me ever if
I wasn't associated with Destiny, right?
But I don't like there's no
coordination. They watch my stream
because Destiny is unhinged about me.
They watch my stream and also a bunch of
the people who are docked were docked
before I was even a streamer or docked
before I had ever like uh known about
Destiny's like obvious consent
violations. He like he tries to pile up
all of these things as if they're like
all related or all connected. They're
really not.
Here, we'll just we'll go through this
again.
>> Who are three days ago, I think in one
page of my thread, five different people
who are close to me got doxed for not
being hard enough against me. Like five
different people in the span of 24
hours. That sounds really bad.
Five different people close to him got
doxed. That sucks. Now, Destiny, keeping
up on Kiwi Farms and being somebody
who's very concerned about those people,
obviously would have gone ahead and like
helped those people out, right? He would
have done something to make sure that
those people were not going to like that
they were informed and not scared and
like, "Hey, this is not a big deal,
right?" Obviously.
Okay.
Uh, Destiny, send it to them so they can
see what's going on, what they what they
are doing. Send it to who? Josiah and
Hutch and stuff. Oh, me. They can figure
it out themselves.
I thought these were people close to
you, Destiny. I thought these were
people close to you that you're implying
like you care about and you're very,
very offended on their behalf. Nah, they
can figure it out themselves.
Are you serious?
Are you Are you kidding me? He does this
all the time, by the way. He'll he'll go
and he'll virtue signal about I can't
believe they put Molina in this lawsuit
because it violated her privacy like
that. I can't believe they put Cherry in
this lawsuit. You violated their privacy
like that. It's like you don't give a
about their privacy. You've violated
their consent. You violated their
privacy repeatedly. Why are you virtue
signaling about this degenerate?
And here again, he's like now on stream
the next day virtue signaling about
this. But when he was said, somebody
says, "Hey, would you send this stuff
along to them?" He goes, "No, they can
figure it out themselves."
Very sad. Very embarrassing. total piece
of total degenerate. Okay,
he blocked all of them on Twitter. He
doesn't seem close to them. But when
he's virtue signaling to his audience,
he'll say, "Oh, it's five people close
to me." And he seems very concerned.
He's like, "This is unacceptable. That's
why I'm doxing people. I didn't dox
these people. I don't I don't like
doxing. I hate doxing." But he's like
trying to come after me, trying to dox
me. Bailed, by the way, but trying to
dox me.
And I don't have anything to do with
this. But he doesn't even care about
these people. He just wants a way to
attack me for criticizing him, right?
That's all he's wanted the whole time.
He doesn't care about them. The care the
performative caring about them, the
performative idea that he cares about
them is is totally fake. Does not give a
just doesn't give a. And it's so
transparent. And you know, you'd think
Very Violet would see this and go, "Oh
man, maybe this guy isn't such a good
person." But no, he's totally he's
totally swallowed all of the jizz. He's
like he's in
Sorry. I try to I try to use the [__]
vampire thing and uh I think of it like
blood and now it's like g it's too
gross. I sound like destiny. I can't do
that analogy.
But he's um he's he's on Twitter
defending Destiny still. He's like all
over the place defending Destiny.
Like it's crazy.
Why wouldn't this like give you a good
idea that this person's like kind of
inhuman,
right? That he's pretending like this
doxing is such a huge deal to him and
then when you're like, "Hey, we should
reach out. Those guys are your former
friends. We should reach out." Nah, they
can figure it out themselves.
Okay. I I guess so.
I guess so. Um and it's like very
blatant, too. Like they don't like try
to hide it. They'll be like, "Oh, like
um I saw like Hutch said this thing on
this. Does anybody have his docs? Does
anybody dox him before?" it'll be like
super blatant and it also sucks cuz it's
hard to even talk about it cuz even just
by saying that in a way I've kind of
sort of like now passed along his docs,
you know, but the fact that like Kiwi
Farms exists to do that
>> very concerning when he went to his chat
and literally put the links to the pages
in his chat.
>> You have all these kind of like snark
subreddits um or like places like um
like Discord servers. We'll say like
just Discord server. Um
>> apparently again this is like a a snark
discord server.
I think he also Yeah, dude.
>> where they kind of like engage in this
behavior. The fact that this goes to
unhinged people online like bad empanada
and then I'm using the Hassan model here
to do this and then all of this stuff
gets repeated uncritically by people
like Casey Tron and Denims and then he
hasn't even said dude information comes
bad stuff comes out from these things.
It's like is it doxing? There's no
doxing. Doxing is not allowed in my in
my no creator has been doxed through my
never never happened.
>> Um or like places like um like Discord
servers will say like just to go
>> and in the future if that were to ever
happen the person who did it would be
permanent from every single platform I
have automatically
>> discord server um where they kind of
like engage in this behavior. The fact
that this goes to unhinged people online
like bad
>> they engage in this behavior. So
engaging in snark-l like behavior. We
don't have to describe the behavior cuz
we're just going to web that together,
right? We don't have to we don't have to
describe it. We just say snark jtock
snark jtock snark. Keep in mind when he
pulls up the logs of people making fun
of him, it's people calling him fat,
right? People calling him fat and then
people like laughing about uh what how
he like can barely hold on to a cat or
something. It's like the it's like the
lightest ribbing.
It's like nothing. It's like nothing.
Every time he looks at logs, it is
nothing.
Like the said about me in his chat is
far worse. Far worse.
>> Empanada. And then I'm using the Hassan
model here to do this. And then all of
this stuff.
>> Okay. So it so stuff from from Jtock or
Snark goes to bad empanada.
>> It's repeated uncritically by people
like Casey Tron and Frogan and Denims.
And then Hassan will directly like give
credence or sometimes even him like you
don't have to take my word for it.
Hassan already spoke in the past. Where
where does he give credence to like
totally unfounded things? Do you guys
remember? This is what I'm talking
about. This is why like this is why like
this happened. We'll get to like the
genesis of this. By the way, did did
this bad empanada Hassan connection
exist before a certain campaign against
a certain streaming website existed?
Did this did this whatever this thing is
up here? Did any of this exist before
somebody escalated it to that point or I
forget. Destiny, it's almost like
somebody used your community to escalate
things to this point. No.
H. But regardless, do you guys remember?
So, he's saying, "Oh, Hassan will
sometimes repeat these things
uncritically, too." Do you remember what
happened when the CPS and the the stuff
came out? Do you remember what Hassan
said? No, guys. That's stupid. He didn't
retweet anything on it and he said,
"That's stupid. Ethan's a good dad. Shut
the up. Stop being weirdos."
Right? That's what he said. So this idea
that even Hassan's just taking
everything bad empanata says and like
repeating it uncritically that's
complete
asked about like never hosting people
like bad empanada. Um
this model is impossible to well it's
not impossible to fight against but it's
it's a I shouldn't say that way it's
just a different it's just a different
weaponization of like doxing and
harassment that didn't exist in the
past. Um,
yeah.
I didn't say Hassan doesn't spread
rumors. I'm saying he doesn't do it
totally uncritically or with like total
malice, right? That's that's the way
he's painting it. I'm saying Hassan
would have been super Ethan there, but
he went, "No, no, no. Here's the line.
I'm not I'm not doing that. That
obviously
>> it's Yeah, I don't know how to I don't
know what the
son told Adam Freeland Destiny debates
his wife." Destiny 100% debated his
wife. What are you talking about? That
was like literally one of Molina's
primary complaints was I can't even I
can't even have like concerns because
I'll get debated out of my concerns.
What are we talking about? Solution is
or the counter
>> I think Dinglingus is is uh messing
around.
>> This is um is this why Aspen subreddit
has gone so conservative? I don't I
don't I don't see conservative groups do
this, but maybe they do do this. Um and
I just don't see it because I'm not in
those spaces. I'm not sure.
Hold on. Destinity.
network doxing. We I my stream has no
relation to doxing. My my stream, my
discord, no relation to doxing anyone
around Destiny at all. I think the worst
thing that's happened is we've had some
people who get in romantic relationships
or they're really good and they get in
fights and they will like dox each other
like chatters. And it's like, okay,
those people got to go. Those people
have to be separated. That's really
weird, right? But like that's not a
culture in this. It's like literally a
hard rule against it. So I don't know
what we're I don't know what we're
doing.
vertical integration like
um the GOP. True. Yeah.
>> Are you talking about the map? I'm
talking about like he has me connected
here and he's like this is somebody said
decentralized or the the like vertical
integration of doxing and it's like dude
I don't I literally don't do I don't
participate in doxing. Don't believe in
it.
Oh, but it's funny because um
somebody typed this message yesterday.
It was so true and I never thought about
it this way before. Apparently, oh look,
we have a schizo theory from somebody
else.
Guys, guys, I'm going to say some insane
coming up, okay? But understand that I'm
just reading someone else's message, so
it's fine.
Uh JTO's connected to bad and Panata
apparently. We'll get to why that
happened in just a little bit, I think.
Um, oh, there's so there's another place
where this also happens that's
comparable to justical um and like snark
subreddits and I would call it it's like
in between Kiwi Farms and Snark
subreddits. It's called um spicy chat.
Um. Oh,
it's sp guys. Guys, it's spicy chat.
It's Uhoh. Oh, we forgot. Dude, he's
just going to get all of his enemies on
this chart. All right. I would be
shocked by the end by the end of all of
this by the end of all of these
lawsuits, we'll have like Molina will be
at the top like having directed all of
this against him or something. Okay.
He'll got he'll have every single person
who's ever said something bad about him
on this chart.
chart. Yeah, the the map.
>> This is um Chub Logic's like degenerate.
You
>> mean the web
>> place basically like a crazy chat in his
Discord where people do like a bunch of
this like doxing and spreading of
information and everything, right?
>> So apparently Chud Logic, our our good
friend of the stream, Chud Logic, is
allowing a bunch of doxing and
degenerate to happen in spicy chat. Very
sad. You hate to see it. Um,
>> surely we're going to see any
substantiation of this at all. He's not
just going to make things up, right?
Surely, surely we'll see some
substantiation, something. There's got
to be something.
Somebody said to me, there's a couple
more interesting things about the spicy
chat commentary sphere. I've realized
one, um, they have an OP strategy of dis
that's a good point, Mark Cardi. Hold
on. I forgot. Dan was a open and w like
happy participant in spicy chat for
months. Did he not did he not point any
of this doxing out to Destiny that
happens? Dan sat in spicy chat all the
time. He went he came into spicy chat.
He took pictures of his cars. Hey guys,
look at I'm I'm repairing my car. Guys,
look. I'm repairing my car. Isn't this
cool? Why is he so friendly with all of
these doctors? I believe Dan just left
spicy chat recently.
where someone in their audience will do
something crazy and the creator will say
I really disavow this in a sarcastic
tone but a laugh at it and say that's so
funny but I disavow but that was cool
lol it creates there's that second part
doesn't happen it's I totally disavow
that it's a it's a joke when it's like
something funny and unhinged gets said I
totally disavow that that's crazy do not
do that right but that's a chat meme
that's not like a that's not like a
spicy chat meme that's just like a
that's a streamer chat meme
And by the way, like lots of the things
you disavow, you'll say, "No, no, no,
no." Like that can't be allowed in my
community, right? I would never allow
that in my community.
>> This environment where the audience has
signal that any crazy behavior is
acceptable because it created plausible
deniability.
>> Yeah. No, Dan is still in the
>> Discord against the bad thing. They've
been doing this with that empanada a lot
recently where he's become like funny
and cool in this community. Yeah. The
funny things bad empanada does are like
going into a video game and somebody he
says is like an IDF secretary mimicking
Ela Klein. That's funny and I disavow
it, but it is funny. When bad empanada
doxes people, there's no hah, that's so
funny, but I disavow but it's kind of
funny. No, it's I totally disavow that.
You shouldn't do that. That's gross,
right? There's no there's no equivocate.
There's nothing happening there that
gives any indication that we're okay
with it.
I even go out of my way when badit
happens to people I hate like Willie
Mack, I'll go out of my way to say
that's gross. That's disgusting. That
that's stupid. like that. That can't be
a thing. You can't get mad at this guy
for his internet commentary and put his
wife at risk. That's sick. Don't do
that. Right. That's my approach. But it
doesn't matter here. I'm getting webbed
into apparently people who do this. I
don't even know who would do this about
actual doxing. I don't think so. Using
spicy chat for separation too. Um using
spicy chat for separation for the
>> separation from what behavior. Uh just
etc. talk like 10 times more there than
even their own community. And all of the
biggest Kiwi Farmes psychos are there as
well. So apparently we talk there more
than our own communities, which is
obvious. How much does Destiny talk in
his Discord?
Is there a reason you think that like
people would talk somewhere else where
they're not like the guy who the
community is built around? Do you guys
think that might happen for like a
reason?
It's because obviously like people want
to ask you questions. They want to ask
you about content. They want to ask you
about what you said on stream. Sometimes
it's nice to go somewhere where you just
like chill and say hi to people and
yeah, it's fine, right? But also,
there's the biggest Kiwi Farm skits
there apparently.
Dude, it's like here's a funny tweet.
Here's a funny tweet. What do you guys
think? Here's Look at this funny thing
that I'm laughing about. I don't Bro,
again, I feel like it's bordering it's
bordering. It's not quite there on like
these people's inability to detect like
friendship like uh like hey here's a
funny thing I saw for example uh they
were recently posting pics of I mean I
guess I'll say it it's sad but like of
like um Willie is getting married and
they've been like posting pictures of
his wife and um and then joing
pictures of Willy's wife in spicy chat
about how he got honeypotted by the IDF.
Um and
>> I made that joke. Sorry. That's a funny
joke. Okay, that's a funny joke. I don't
begrudge people who make fat jokes about
me because they think that docs photos
of me. Okay, I don't begrudge those
people. It's fine. Unfortunately for
Willy's wife, I think is or something
and was literally in the IDF or
something and it's just a funny joke.
I'm sorry. It's a funny joke. I don't
even know if I made that joke about
Willie. I think I made that joke about
Nicholas.
Can we Can we check and make sure
there's no IDF baddies in Nicholas's
life right now? Okay, we can't lose
another one.
>> Then three. Then Queen and Agistical can
forever act above it. But a large core
of their fan base exists in and around
spicy chat. They can indefinitely call
doxing bad and pretend that Willie is
crazy while ostensibly the core of their
communities.
What do you mean call Willie crazy?
Dude. Dude, the tweet. So my tweet, my
retweet of dickers is a freeze frame of
a quote tweet. Like there's a video in
the quote tweet that could be a clip
that is somebody else. I think Queen or
somebody else literally looking at
Destiny's quote tweet of that, right?
It's Destiny's quote tweet. All of it at
Bedrock is Destiny's quote tweet of the
Gatumodor person, right? That's what
everybody's commenting on. That's how
everybody saw it. That is how everyone
saw it. That's what blew it up. Cuz
Destiny's willing to amplify anybody's
docs to make other people look to make
people he doesn't like look bad, right?
He doesn't care if amplifying that docs
hurts those people. He will amplify that
docs to make and anybody criticizing him
look bad. That's what he wants more than
anything in the world.
That's transparent, right? It's obvious.
That's why he did it with Hutch's Docks
just recently. That's why he'll keep
doing it with Hutch's Docks. That's why
he did it with Willy's Docks. He wants
everybody against him to look bad.
That's his only goal.
It was Queen. I'm saying it's Queman.
Yeah. Yeah. It's Queman reviewing a clip
and he doesn't even have the sound on.
He's just talking about it, right?
But it has like some dox in there.
God, doxing is so bad. But you guys
should dox all these people off my
platform because it's toos. No, he
doesn't even say off my if you use DG
chat. Apparently that's fine with him.
That's where he does his doxing.
Um, Obsidian. No, no, no. He's not
doxing Hutch. He Well, I guess it
depends on how you put it. He decided
that Hutch apparently was doxed on KF
and he was going to go into his chat and
start posting those links right to Hutch
to where Hutch was doxed and then I
think Riyle made a tweet with those logs
which by the way I don't know why that
happened. It was a little weird for me
to find out that like Destiny had at the
same time finding out Destiny had
apparently like tried to dox me again
with a different person. All right, that
I found out that Riyle was like re was
like amplifying that and then Destiny
was quote tweeting him. I don't even
know what the [__] going on, right?
Nobody was posting Lily's wife and spicy
so far as I've seen. Yeah, I wouldn't
think that was happening. Most most
people like the spicy mods understand
that there are unhinged like DJs and
that would want to report them, right?
Like most of those people realize that
so they keep it pretty clean in there.
Anyway, so Destiny's like amplifying
anyway. Yeah. So something did happen
with Hutch by the way. Ogre Boy.
That did happen.
He's so stupid with his schizo mappings
he forgot to attach you and the starkers
to KF for his narrative to work. Well,
apparently, yeah, I don't know. I like
like literally he has argued, yes, that
like I am apparently attached to this,
but somebody told him that like there's
a layer of separation which is spicy
chat where doc's information gets
posted. I would just love to see any
evidence of this. Literally any evidence
at all. Oh, wait, hold on. There is some
evidence. Somebody came in with uh my
picture, like the picture they're saying
is me, the new one. Some some picture of
that as like an avatar to spicy chat. So
technically, somebody is trying to dox
me. Thank god Desty's. He's continuing
to miss. Okay, somebody tried to dox
that photo in spicy chat. But I don't
think that was like Cleman or me. That
would be weird. Huh. Is directly part of
it. I
>> believe that person got banned, but I'm
not sure.
>> I guess Chud Logic just doesn't care
about any backlash or having it attached
to a server. He's pretty much like
Joshua Moon in that sense. Um, null.
Sorry for doxing you.
>> I think Chud would be pretty I think
Chud would be like
livid if people were just doxing people
in spicy chat.
>> I've been looking how they behave the
last few days. And that spicy chat
community is incredibly militant. Any
post that gets linked there, you can see
the same names commenting and brigading.
If they link a stream there, you can see
the same names like up chat and then
spinning weird narratives.
Does Destiny Hold on. If If we just took
that, okay, we just took that and we
disconnected it from the community
that's already been referenced. How
would any of that not apply to DGG chat
and them embedding streams?
Can we can we get any distinction here
at all? Any backlash or having it
attached to a server? He's pretty much
like Joshua Moon in that sense. Um,
nulling you.
I've been liking how they behave the
last few days and that spicy chat
community is incredibly militant. Any
post that gets linked there, you can see
the same names commenting and brigading.
Never happened with a tweet that's
posted that's critical of Destiny in DGG
chat. It's never been brigaded ever.
>> They link a stream there. You can see
the same names.
Stream gets linked. It's never been Are
we serious? Is this actually Is this guy
a idiot?
How do you not how do you not just do
the the self-critique there and say,
"Wait, could this be applied to my
community?" Yeah, obviously it can
literally talk about that today because
of the Quinio Discord pirate software. I
have no idea what you're talking and
then spinning weird narratives.
Yeah, but it's like it's it's annoying
and weird because like people like
weaker people like Dioro will get pulled
into this like sphere and then all of
these people become this like focus of
uh like this vector for attacking
anybody that they deem as being like an
enemy.
Weaker people like Doro get pulled into
this sphere and influenced and they
become a vector to attack people. Is he
trying to imply that like Nicholas Dioro
didn't really have criticism of him, but
he was just getting like mind by spicy
chat? Is that what he's trying to say?
Like actually, no. Nicholas Nicholas
should never he would never have gone
after me if he wasn't totally minded by
by Chudlo Logic. Guys, that's obvious,
isn't it? Nicholas would never have gone
after me if he wasn't mind read by
Chudlogic in his community.
Huh? Narratives brigading. If they link
a stream there, you can see the same
names like up chat and then spinning
weird narratives.
Yeah, but it's like it's it's annoying
and weird because like people like
weaker people like Dioro will get pulled
into this like sphere. Oh,
fantastic point. Right. Right.
Weak-minded because he's hopped off of
being like friends with Dan. Right. He's
hopped off of being friends with Dan. He
was like, "No, no, no. I don't like
doxing actually, guys. And got Willie to
cancel that podcast. Dude, dude,
I totally forgot about that.
Such a It's all amazing clips. Yes, this
person has zero self-awareness at all.
No self-awareness. We haven't even
gotten to the part where the entire
Twitch anti-semitism
campaign started with Dan saying, "Hey,
Dan Clancy, I've got pictures of you and
your kids at the beach. What are you
going to do now? I've got all of your
[__]
Uh, what? That's how this started.
That's how this whole thing, the bad
empanada connection to these people and
Hassan, that's how that all started. By
the way, these people were very loosely,
a lot of these people totally disavowed
bad empanada. But it turns out when you
get the bad empanada on Destiny's side
going after all of these people, they
turn to someone they don't fully
understand. Okay? They turn to
Where's the Alfred? Where's the Alfred
and Bruce Wayne scene? Okay.
Uh, they don't fully understand. Okay,
Bad Empanada is actually the Joker.
Okay, Bad Empanada is actually the joke.
Uh, this is Dan, by the way. He's like,
I knew they wouldn't go down without a
fight, but I didn't I didn't think
they'd do this whole thing here. We
don't need the whole thing. Okay, some
men just want to watch the B world burn.
That's how it ends. All right, we don't
need the whole thing.
But like, it's actually it is just
they're doing they're engaging in the
same behavior. They're going back and
forth and this these links weren't that
strong before the Twitch anti-semitism
thing before they started going hard on
Hassan and and Twitch in general
>> and [__] And then
>> I'm not become this like focus of uh
like this vector for attacking anybody
that they deem as
>> Oh, we'll go back to Nicholas being
weakminded.
>> People like Dioro will get pulled into
this like sphere. annoying and weird
because like people like weaker people
like Dioro will get pulled into this
like sphere and and then all of these
people become this like
>> focus of uh like this vector for
attacking anybody that they deem as
being like an enemy.
Oh yeah,
Destiny talking about you and Chud. So
apparently Nicholas is just a vector to
attack other people. Nicholas doesn't
have any sensience of his own. He's just
a vector to attack other people. Who's
he been attacking this whole time? Oh,
all of your enemies, Destiny. Wow,
that's weird. That's almost like you're
projecting something there. Do you feel
like you've been controlling Nicholas to
attack your enemies directly for months
and months and months or something? Very
interesting. Yes, we get the Pepe Silva
thing. Uh I I hesitate to use this cuz I
do believe the person who linked this
warned me that this uh apparently got
posted on Kiwi Farms. This will this
will prove the link, guys. The fact that
I use an image that was also posted on
Kiwi Farms, that will prove that
apparently there's a link between these
people. It's all connected. It's all
connected, guys. It's It's all
connected. It's there. We can put them
all together. We can all We can connect
it all. It's all connected.
Okay. Okay.
Riyle Justical's editor retweets bada
and posts his stuff in other subreddits.
Banana docs a few days ago. How
retweets? I don't have any idea. I I
retweet some clips from Ry on Twitter. I
got no idea about that. Um
I'd have to see what he's retweeting bad
empanada doing. I guess I have no
financial ties to Riyle and I have no
control over him. Um I I can't tell him
what to do. I cannot control his if he
goes crazy. That sucks. That kind of
sucks. But like I he basically posts my
on on YouTube for no like for just the
money that he would get out of the
channel, right? Like we don't have a
financial tie, but I don't like
copyright strike him because I want my
stuff to be on YouTube. That's the
That's the tie we have. All right.
>> This is not a direct endorsement of doxy
just works well because disco will
always say things like, "Oh, well, when
I retweeted it was two layers deep,
right?" They'll always like Okay, that
is true though. Wait, you have to
actually look at the facts. Sorry, I'm
By the way, I don't even know that any
of that happened with Riyle. I just
don't know. Right. I'm sure Riyle has
like a a strong sense of like what he's
done is correct or or right, and he
could just explain himself, right?
>> Disount. But anyway, that's why I'm
saying like on a from like a moral
level. The only reason that I don't
allow doxing or anything,
>> a lot of people that posted the anarchic
thread on KF were probably DJers.
Doesn't that implicate Destiny?
According to Destiny, yes,
absolutely.
>> Unlike any of my platforms where it's
against QS is because it's against
>> Destiny would absolutely be responsible
for the anthread, any lab stuff that's
on there, any Mac stuff that's on there.
Yeah, Destiny would absolutely be
responsible.
>> In terms of like morality or ethics, I
don't give a [__] about Well, I
basically the same I guess I said to
Will. I don't care about any of these
people. Um, these people are absolutely
unhinged and crazy. And I and I don't
think I'll say this too. Um,
all of these people are unhinged and
crazy. This entire sphere of people who
I've connected through no evidence
through just my skitso machinations,
they're all crazy and unhinged. They
might have BPD. They might be mentally
ill. They might be. Okay. All of these
people. All of them. And maybe it's just
because I'm a public figure, so I maybe
maybe that's why I take this chance. I
think that if you're going to spend all
of your entire life obsessing over and
like covering drama and being so
peripherilally attached to doxing
communities, I don't think you deserve.
>> So peripherally attached. So not
attached at all.
So not not attached at all then.
>> Anonymity anyway. You should absolutely
be unmasked. Everybody should know who
>> if you're going to cover drama, you
should be doxed according to Destiny.
Huh. What? What's your problem with
Willie?
What would Wait, what would what would
Destiny's problem with Willie getting
docks? I have a problem with Willie
getting docks, by the way. Okay.
Uh, I'm not even going to read that. Uh,
get rid of that. I don't want that in my
chat. Sorry, Pensive. Go, don't say like
that, please. No. No. I will literally
time you people out.
I'll actually start timing you people
out.
Uh, hold on. You got to go for an hour
or something. Sorry, Mark Carney. You're
out.
Nope. Nope. None of that. None of that.
Now you
>> none of that now.
>> Ezekiel Snake, thank you for the five
months. Thank you. Thank you. But like
he he's arguing why a bunch of people
around him would be complicit, right? Is
he not
like if you could just make these
connections. Oh, you have a positive
relationship with this. Oh, you've like
cited something from here. If that's the
level, if that's the the the bar to meet
for people to be collaborators, then it
seems like, oh, literally everybody on
everybody's connected to someone, okay,
you follow enough degrees, okay, six
degrees of Kevin Bacon, but six degrees
of who whoever I wanted docs on the
internet. All of your entire life
obsessing over and like covering drama
and being so peripherilally attached to
doxing communities, I don't think you
deserve anonymity anyway. You should
absolutely be unmasked. Everybody should
know who you are and if they want to
find your address and whatever all the
same they do to me and any of these
other people involved. Oh, don't forget
that's part of the part and parcel of
being an online figure. So yeah,
wow.
Apparently he just gets to dox people.
It's part and parcel of being an online
figure. Remember the impetus for him
doxing people is other people getting
doxed. I don't understand how this logic
follows. Apparently it's part and parcel
being an online figure, right? But if if
someone else doxes somebody close to
him, even though that's part and parcel
of being an online figure, he's going to
dox me or queen or I don't even know
where he go from here. Probably looking
at chatters, I have no idea.
Like the things he says make no sense.
Oh, also he's really he's so upset that
he'll have to dox other people, but he's
not going to let any of those people
know that they got doxed either. Listen,
I'm not trying to [__] on you or
anything, but your explanation of their
reaction to unhinged behavior reminds me
of when DJ was sapping Vosch around the
time.
>> Wait, wait, wait. I have to listen to
that again.
>> Their reaction to unhing nope nope nope
nope. Destiny, not trying to anything,
but your explanation of their reaction
to unhinged behavior reminds me of when
DJ was sapping Vos around the time of
his debate about the definition of a
woman. I mean,
remember all of those harassment
campaigns your community like openly
engaged in and coordinated via DG chat?
Yeah. Isn't this like a little
hypocritical, Destiny? I mean, I mean,
you know, like technically probably I'm
like one of the worst when it comes to
this, but uh you know, no, no, no. If
somebody did that to me, like there was
an account in my subreddit that was like
a secret Vosch fan and was like kind of
like, would it be annoying? Sure. But
that's not even remotely on the same
level as that. That's not even You can
say it's bad or wrong. I guess if we
want to, which is maybe fair, but I
wouldn't even agree with that cuz I know
there's gay ops in my um subreddit all
the time, but I'm not saying they're the
same. Just give me a fond memory. Oh,
sure. Sure. Yeah. Like people are always
going to ask Turf and do stuff like
that, which I mean like if you find a
banner, but bridge building with Daily
Wire, etc. was very good. You got
understandably frustrated, but really
only after one interaction with each
individual. After two to three, you
start to digging on topics and win
people over. You have to understand that
Jordan Peterson and Candace Owens were
committed to never talking to me again.
>> So, hold on. These are the These are the
tweets that Riyle has retweeted a bad
empanada. Hold on. Let's see. When When
he says Riyle has retweeted bad
empanada, let's see what it is. It is
all YouTubers/ streamers who use those
bouncy cartoon rant sonas need to be put
into camps now. So, this is me. This is
him retweeting something about me being
put into a camp. Bouncy cartoon rant
sonas. This is literally him tweeting
something that's funny because it
targets me.
Just to be clear, that's that's it. And
then the other one he retweeted is a
response to not so erodite. Okay, it's a
response to not so erodite. You work for
the guy who revitalized Fuentes's
career, but also he hasn't genocided
hundreds of thousands of people. You
[__]
So this is not like an unhinged.
Apparently these are what make you
worthy of being included in the bad
empanada sphere and doable. Is this
my brother?
Do you see how he just he totally lies,
right? He just totally lies about like
what's going on. Well, apparently he he
retweets Ban and Panata. Doesn't it
matter what gets retweeted?
Does it not matter at all? Okay. See,
that's why we just look into stuff and
all of his claims fall apart because he
doesn't care. He's just going to lie.
And nobody in his audience will ever
check him because they are losers. And
they need somebody who makes them feel
like they're not losers. And the best
they've ever found online is Destiny.
So Riyle was bad empanada the whole
time. Apparently,
let's see. I don't know if there's more
to this video.
>> A nice conversation. I would think in
retrospect, I think I would have rather
just not talked to them or had that
first conversation been hardcore. Um,
the more I think about it, the more I am
actually like really really bothered. I
actually hate the fact that stupid on my
subre that posted this has been
destroying my mind. Um, and I think that
is actually true that a lot of people
just don't really view Trump as being
that bad. I think a lot of people just
don't view the Trump stuff as being that
bad. They just don't. Um,
>> is he done with this? He might be moving
on.
>> The boiling It's the boiling pot frog.
Looking at this girl's Twitter will help
him feel like not a loser. Hold on.
Hold on. What is this? What is this? My
DMs are open for apologies. Yes, queens.
And any other calculation to my
intellectual superiority?
What?
MAGA will never accept the fact that
Trump is a kitty because they'd be too
depressed that Trump didn't their kid.
I'm going to be real, man. And I think a
lot of the right wants answers as well.
Unless you're talking about the
extremists and then well yeah obviously
there's going to be they're going to be
Trump doesn't release the Epstein files.
Would you say it would have been better
to vote for Camala? Let's call about it
sometime. I'm streaming for three more
hours today. Wow. Aite built a bridge.
Oh my god. To a another predator.
Another another person who doesn't
respect consent. Another p total piece
of who totally lies about everybody
around him all the time. Let's go
connect these narcissistic sociopaths.
Let's go. Bridges built. Let's
awesome. Awesome. You love to see it.
You love to see it. Oh, you love to see
it.
We're going to get We're going to get
everybody with like a weird We're going
to get them all on the same all on the
same team, guys. Okay. We just need we
need to get every consent violating
brick pointing in the right direction
and we're gonna have a bridge. All
right.
Oh,
for TeeOne alleged for Teone alleged.
Okay. Alleged consent violations
should be clear. Do you ever review that
conversation between Teone and Aerodite?
Nope. But maybe we will. Maybe we will.
Maybe we'll go and we'll be very, very,
very unhinged and obsessed and go after
it.
Limited immunity deal for Aeronite.
That is how this all ends. Limited
immunity deal for not so Aeronite. Okay,
but why would anybody compare you to
Glenn Maxwell? I can't think of why. Oh
my god.
H. Okay. All right.
I think that's it for for that. I think
that's it. Hold on. Let me see.
Is this the same one? This is the same
one, isn't it?
>> I can't believe no one is talking about
that ninja. Wait, hold on. That's
unrelated. Do you mean they don't view
it as bad or don't understand that it's
bad?
>> I think this is over, right?
>> And the topic, the main topic today is
>> Oh, hold on.
>> There was a guy who wip
>> What is this? This kid was on stream
yesterday saying he desperately wants to
debate you over this Willie Max docs
thing. Yeah, but I don't care. This is
Hold on. It's going to be an Aiden clip.
Oh, it's going to be an Aiden clip.
>> Technically correct on
>> I just I scanned and saw the hair. I saw
that clearly Destiny's not going to want
to talk to Aiden though because he is
going to get PTSD about talking to
Britney Simon. Okay, that's He's going
to be He's going to be like, "What the
fuck?" Okay, Britney, if you want to
talk to me, you don't have to get a
change. You can just talk to me. You can
just message me. Okay. every point, but
on the concept, on the macro, everybody
knows that he's wrong.
>> Destiny Destiny is trying to explain
this is literally Destiny is going to
repeat the exact critique right-wingers
have of him, right? If I if like he's
going to Yeah, he's going to bog this
down in little pedantic points because
he's going to go, "Oh, well, factually,
you can't demonstrate this. You couldn't
quite demonstrate that." And he's going
to bog it down. But if you look at the
macro, if you look at everything put
together, if you look at the
constellation, then you know that I'm
correct, right? All we have to do is
look at everything in aggregate and then
it's obvious I'm correct,
>> right? This is this is the exact thing
he mocked every right-winger for with
regards to January 6th or QAnon,
anything to do with Trump, right? He
mocks them all for this exact same
reason. He's about to explain why he
would lose a debate to Aiden on the
substance of this or anybody on the
substance of this. And it's because,
well, guys, listen. Maybe they could
prove that I like can't connect things.
Maybe they could show that I don't have
evidence for anything I'm saying. But in
aggregate, in aggregate, okay? In
aggregate. They all know I'm right. They
all know I'm correct. In aggregate,
guys, they all know. They all know it's
all connected. In aggregate, they know.
They know. They know. They know. on the
macro. Yes, you quote something Canadian
Willy's docs that Tiny also reposted uh
that Willy Willie also did. No, no, no,
no, no. I retweeted Pensive Goat. To be
clear, I retweeted somebody who was
criticizing Destiny's hypocrisy on
doxing, right? who themselves was doing
so via quote tweet of somebody who was
making a comment on a clip from Quean
where Quean was criticizing Destiny on
his hypocrisy on doxing via Destiny's
quote tweet of Gatof Fumador where Gatof
Fumodor included some pictures of
Willy's docs and Destiny was saying this
is bad or Destiny was saying nothing
done against bad empanada would be bad.
Oh the Gatop Fumador clip is from a bad
empanada video. Okay, that's how far you
have to go down that hill to understand
like where the actual information was.
And it's all, by the way, from Destiny's
quote tweet. That's where we all found
it was Destiny quote tweeting this and
blowing it up for everybody. So, I don't
I don't I don't accept any
responsibility for that at all.
And and Willie Willy's been posting
like, "Well, he removed it, so thank you
to him for that." No, I didn't. Dickers
removed it. I would have left it up
there cuz I don't think I did anything
wrong. I don't think anything wrong was
done there.
I thought it was literally in the tweet
you retweeted based on how DG portrayed
it. No, it was not. It was literally the
tweet I retweeted had nothing of that
information. The quote tweet from that
person had a picture of the Gat Fumodor
Destiny retweet, right? Was on Queman's
screen. So, they're commenting on Queen
stuff and Quimman was commenting on the
the Destiny quote tweet, but like the
screenshot doesn't include any
information about Willie. You'd have to
click into that and then you'd have to
watch a bunch of the clip to see
anything.
So, the tweet as it was on my timeline
has no information about Willie Mack in
it. No doxing information, no PII.
Okay.
And Willie, by the way, didn't message
Dickers to get that taken down. Willie
just see about it publicly, thereby
trying to make it seem like I was
amplifying it when he knows that it's
all commentary on Destiny's quote tweet
and Destiny was the one amplifying it
massively because Destiny's trying to
get a gotcha on bad empanada and doesn't
give a about Willie or his wife or his
wedding. [__] you, Willie. Okay,
according to Destiny, it's you your wife
everybody cuz I need to make a great
tweet about bad empanada. That's how
Destiny sees the world. Okay, so you
keep defending him. You keep coming
after me if you want, but this is the
guy who's trying to with your wedding.
I don't don't get it twisted, buddy.
Okay. I don't I don't want your wedding
up. He does. Hey, this is a game where
he's going to be.
>> Destiny ran from dickers today. I wish
Destiny would unblock me so I could
quote tweet his
What is this? Destiny, I'm streaming.
I'm in I'm in stream disagreements. Read
JTO tweet. I am the guy who wrote the
original tweet. Oh, did Destiny not want
to talk to him or
h
Let's see what his cope is on Aiden
here.
>> This is the thing because like this is a
game, right? This is a game where he's
going to be technically correct on every
point, but on the concept, on the macro,
everybody knows that he's wrong. Where
it's like if you look at the exact
tweets that Justical tweeted, you'll
actually see that there was actually no
ducks in the exact when you look at the
quote tweet. And that when you look at
his chat, anybody that posted docs is
actually
>> So yeah, when you look at the facts,
when you looked at when you look at the
facts of the matter, uh it's clear he
didn't dox him. Yes, that is everybody's
argument but yours, Destiny. But when
you look at the aggregate, if you look,
guys, if you look at the aggregate,
okay, if you look at it all put, if we
put it all together, if we put it all
together, it's it's clear that he doxed
him. We put it all together banned
immediately and he disavows all forms of
duing and it's like technically you're
correct on everything. Why
dude? What? What? There's no way.
There's no way. Is it that all of the
doctors and all of these people all seem
to be in that community though? Like
isn't that kind of a weird all the do
isn't it weird dude? He is actually
queuing on. Isn't it weird how like
these people Isn't it weird how like all
of the billionaires go to the Bilderberg
meeting and isn't it kind of strange
that like the people with the money seem
to get policy dictated in their favor?
Isn't it like strange? Isn't that weird?
Isn't that odd? He's actually just doing
it. He's actually just doing it.
Brotherh
coincidence. Why isn't it kind of like
spread who who are the doctors in my
community? Who are the doctors in my
community? Why doesn't he say the names
evenly throughout the space? Why does it
seem like all of these people seem to be
>> Do you know Do you know what the actual
connecting thing is? What if he had any
idea of social connection? Any idea how
social groups operate? Um, it turns out
the connecting factor is we all think
you're a weird freak. That's the
connection. We hang out and we were all
present for like all of these leaks
happening and we all think you're a
weird freak. That's the connection. You
solved the conspiracy, bro. We all think
you're a weird freak who looks sort of
like their haircut and their boutique.
Make them look like a not accusing you
of being a by the way. You just look
like one. You look like you have an
unmarked van and you sit outside of
schools. Okay. Not but I don't think you
do that. I'm just saying you look like
you do that. Okay.
You didn't used to be this blatantly
dishonest. I don't know. I want to go
back. Like I feel like going back and
watching things. It's so transparent. It
should be so embarrassing to speak like
this.
He he is actually doing his impression
of like a right-wing conspiracy theorist
that all of the doctors and all of these
people all seem to be in that community
though. Like isn't that kind of a weird
coincidence? Why isn't it kind of like
spread evenly throughout the space? Why
does it seem like all of these people
seem to be in your camp and this is
ignoring all of the collaboration and
side discords?
You are trying to dox me yourself.
Dan openly doxes everybody who crosses
him. What are we talking about?
Yeah, I do have doctors in my Discord.
Dan's still in my Discord. Yes, I do.
You got me. I have Dan in my Discord. I
do have doctors in my Discord. [__] Of
which is hard to even track all of it.
And it's ignoring all of the gay apps in
the multiple accounts because I know of
at least one person um if not two like
50/50 on one of the other accounts who
post both in the Kiwi Farms thread and
in the um Anistical Discord server now
in a side Discord server because of
reasons. But like there's so much like
collaboration. Huh?
Is he talking about Sock Dem Incel? the
guy who like hates me and is banned from
my community was banned like almost
immediately
>> and information exchange. But like this
as long as you have this hardcore like
we disavow and we abandon this had a
direct retweet you bro like it's so
stupid it's so so I don't need any
connection I will never have this is him
by the way saying to all of the people
around him I hope you guys understand
right audite counterpoints you can never
turn on this guy or he will publish
anything he can about you right I hope
you all understand that the actual thing
I've done wrong is be against this
person and the second you turn the
second you step out of line he will
destroy
He'll use anything he can.
That's just so transparently obvious
here, right? He doesn't need a
connection. He doesn't need any actual
pretext. He will make up whatever he
needs to go after you if you turn on
him. Is so unbelievably unserious.
>> In his mind, he's probably going to he's
probably going to I would love to debate
Destiny on this. I would love love love
to debate Destiny on this, bro.
Is Destiny going to run again or is
Destiny knows that he has to run, right?
>> It seems like people are justifying
JTO's docs because of the Willie drama.
Do you think he should? Yes. 100 if if
this is like a widespread thing that
people are using as a wider
justification. 150% he should clarify
that. But also that justification
doesn't really work since Destiny was
looking for JTO's docs and inciting
people to do so long before Willie got
doxed. Oh, that by the way, some people
bring up that screenshot from Chud with
the TDD thing. Right above that
conversation is me discussing with
Destiny or sorry Chud that Desi's like
saying he's going to try to dox me and
Queenman like right above that. It was
literally like that day
just so you know. So like when I'm like
it's obvious [__] it's obvious that it's
this guy. He's a loser.
Five $5 from plants. Glad you're wearing
your nice shirt today. This is my nice
shirt. This is just one of my casual
ones. I appreciate it nevertheless.
>> Okay. I wasn't trying to emulate his
voice before hearing it. Okay. Sorry.
>> I don't like to pick outfits. So, if you
just do like a polo jeans, nice watch.
>> Whoever sign up Destiny into watching
Aiden comment on fashion.
Okay. I can't think of a greater
torture. You won. You won. That person's
a winner. Okay. It just works. Part of
the issue in my view is saying this is
just evil Republicans as they always
have been when I really feel comparing
Bush and Trump are legitimizing a long
time because I'm because it's coming up
now and because of Willie. Why is he
saying that? Um probably because I'm
because it's coming up now over the
Willie stuff, but also because keeps
pretending like the other stuff posted
isn't him.
I guess.
Admit that the doc is you or I'll keep
doxing you. Admit that this is you or
I'll keeping you, brother.
Dude,
just let me you and I'll stop trying to
you, idiot. Just let it happen. Just let
it happen. Guess I just made all of
these accounts like nine years ago with
the same picture and username and
everything. Just a the long con. Oh,
yeah.
>> Are there a lot of accounts like that?
There was this
>> I I pointed out what I thought was
really weird because I have a leak code
account, but there's there's some weird
stuff going on there. I don't know. I
don't know. I'll I'll look into it more
and we'll see.
I We'll see. I asked some people about
it. We're looking into it. Okay. I I
have a feeling he's trying to tie some
things together and he's gotten confused
and it's going to be quite funny and
could be a lot of content, but we'll
see. I'm going to grab a red. One
second.
Oh, is that it? I think Oh, no, no, no.
There's the This clip will actually be
good. Ignorant on every single one.
>> Oh, hold on. But it's interesting that
he'll run from Dickers and Aiden and
everybody, right? He won't talk to
anybody any of these people about it.
It's obvious he's he's just
transparently like given up any attempt
at principles. Like, it's over.
>> Wait, what is this? Why go all ignorant
on every single one of these lives?
Destiny, listen. I like you or I
wouldn't be here, but you need to bring
the interviews, Destiny, to these live
versions of your educational classes. I
don't understand what that means. Who
has led dictatorship in Peru? Chad will
definitely like this. Age restricted 1
hour and 14 minutes made by a dude who
hates me. This has got it all, folks.
Yeah, let me go watch a video.
>> Okay, this is uh this is the bad and
banana thing. I'm going to use bathroom
real quick while this plays. Context for
this clip. I don't need context for this
clip. I know the context for the clip.
>> Tatip improved. chat will definitely
like this. Age restricted 1 hour and 14
minutes. Uh, made by a dude who hates
me. This has got it all, folks. Yeah,
let me go watch a video about a dude who
constantly talks about how I'm a
reactionary fake socialist because I
watch people's videos. That seems like a
good idea. It's age restricted, which
means there's like to violations galore
in there. Bad empanada. The the
cringiest like classic angry leftist who
never shuts the up and is just angry at
the entire planet. You're a
propagandist, dumbass. Like, do it
better. Okay. Your your job is to do
propaganda. Do it better. I thought that
bad a like you he used to. I think he
doesn't like me because he hates the
He's like on board with like the react
gate. He's like, "Wow, Hassan just like
reacts to videos and he's like stealing
other people's labor." Yeah, he he does
not like me. I'm never going to watch a
bad empanada video on this stream. I'm
just letting you guys know. If you think
>> So, like, hold on. Hassan doesn't like
bad empanada cuz bad empanada was mean
to him. Hassan is like a total diva who
doesn't take criticism. Well, wow. Oh,
you're telling me this for the first
time? I had no indications of this. I
had no idea this was the case. All
right. I had no idea. Hassan's Hassan is
a diva who doesn't take criticism. What?
What? No, no, no. No way. You think I'm
going to watch a YouTube essay from a
dude literally openly antagonistic
towards me watching YouTube videos?
You're out of your mind. Okay. You think
I want him to write like
>> why read the question but not answer.
No, I was I'm sorry I sounded like I was
being I just don't understand. Um
I don't understand the question. Why go
ignorant on every single one of these
lives, Destiny? Listen, I like you or I
wouldn't be here, but you need to bring
the interviews
want that at all. Okay. He would perhaps
benefit tremendously if I did watch his
YouTube videos on this channel, but I'm
never going to do that. Okay. Yes,
insane leftists do actually make really
good content uh from time to time. I
think would be one of the
>> Hey, so is there supposed to be an
inconsistency here or
>> better content creators online if you
just didn't have a clear account because
he's such a freak, dude. Oh my lord,
he's such a goddamn freak. He is the
most insane person. He has like 7,000
accounts. I just said I have a an
official blockade on bad empanada videos
on this broadcast while I'm live. That's
number one. And number two, he's not
>> Yeah, it's just wild.
>> Literally, it's literally just Hassan
going I think this guy's like crazy. I
wonder why Hassan after being like
totally gangsted having all of his
brought up from all over the internet
from like 15 years ago, right? Tweets he
had 15 years ago getting brought up and
used against him. I wonder why he might
have been like, you know what, maybe
this bad empanada guy had a point. Maybe
I was not going hard enough on some of
these people. I wonder apparently Hassan
changing his mind on associating with
bad and panata is proof that he is like
uh I don't know fake. What was the
principle there? I don't associate with
people who are mean to me was the
principle.
I guess that he's violated, huh? With
such a subjective with such a subjective
rationale, you'd think we'd almost
expect him to change it at the drop of a
hat. No,
>> I wrote the same letters to the MTV.
What's going on? Why don't you care
about me?
>> Okay. All right. I think that's uh
that's it. Yeah, he's just transparently
stupid about um Hassan. Like, there's no
hypocrisy there. Just be clear, there's
zero hypocrisy on Hassan's part there.
I see no hypocrisy. I don't like this
guy because he criticizes me watching
TV. Yeah, he was probably right about
you. Maybe you realize now that he was
right about you.
I mean, to be fair, it sounded to me
like he's saying he doesn't associate
with crazy people. He was saying he's a
crazy leftist who makes really good
content. I wonder if associating with
crazy people might seem a little more
reasonable, right? There's this clip
from this stream, too. Crazy. Hold on.
What is this? Oh, wait. That's not what
I wanted. It's this.
Oh,
this thing is so for pulling video clips
up. Hold on.
>> Communism and openly endorses terrorism.
See,
>> you won't be seen at all in any capacity
in any hypothetical. Even in a press
conference, even if this
>> Oh, hold on. I might actually I thought
I remember we could actually maybe check
out some of this.
>> You're GG bait because you know that if
you say anything positive even as a
hypothetical, even in comparison to a
major magar like Rob Moore that you
can't even in that context, even in that
crazy context where the
>> it's like this it's this is the same
thing. He doesn't think Hassan is that
bad either. I
Dude, Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. There's
no way. There's no way Destiny said he
would take Hassan uh he would take
Charlie Kirk before Hassan. Is there Is
there any way that Destiny could have
possibly said today that he'd take
Charlie Kirk over Hassan? I Dude, I gave
him the benefit of the doubt. I said
there's no shot. There's no shot that
Destiny would say, "Oh yeah, I'd want
Charlie Kirk to be president over
Hassan."
Oh no.
Oh no. He's completely It's good.
Dude, apparently he said it. Apparently
he said it,
my brother.
>> I can't believe that so much insane has
been radicalized. I This is like the
This is like the precursor to the
Germany, right? But at least they had
like a
Yes, but but Charlie Kirk is gerbles.
Yes, it is like that. But Charlie Kirk
is gerbles.
Dude, dude.
Dude,
much insane has been radicalized. I This
is like
>> He said, "I can't believe how much
insane been radicalized. This like
Germany.
>> I can't believe that so much insane has
been radicalized." I This is like the
This is like the precursor to the
Germany, right? But at least they have
like a reasonarian communism and openly
endorses terrorism.
>> It's all unironically spitebased
reasoning. I know. I know. It's crazy.
It's Ah, no. It was never like that. No.
Axe. No. It was never like that,
dude.
At least they had a reason.
Oh, hold on. Hold on. Wait.
>> Right. But at least they had like a
reason. Communism.
>> That is a funny ending to it. But at
least they had a reason. At least in
Germany, they had a reason. With Assan,
there's just nothing. I can't think of a
single I could I could understand why
you'd vote for but Hassan Hassan
that's got to be clipchimp. Okay, I that
has to be clip chimp.
Bro,
I I just have to go and watch. I have to
go and watch cuz it's it's up here
somewhere. Hold on. Can I refresh this?
Did I have the transcript yet? No. Let
me get Let me see if I can find the
transcript. I just have to search Kirk.
I just have to know on the Charlie Kirk
front. There's no way, right? There's no
way on the Charlie Kirk front we get him
saying like, "Oh, I totally vote for
Charlie Kirk." Or, "I totally take
Charlie Kirk as president over Hassan."
>> Kirk is a fascist.
>> Oh, no. No. This is after. Wait, what?
Oh, he watched the callin first.
Why did he watch the callin first?
What?
There's this I don't know why he would
have done this
>> when we I'm think I think you when we
see like the like some of Hassan's like
pro terrorist
>> they're arguing over if Charlie Kirk or
Hassan would be better as president bro
just me Jesus is like okay I'm I just
hate you more than pretty much anyone
like you're demon and so that like I
could I could sniff it in the
conversation you were having like that's
where he was coming from where he's just
like I like like a person like because
of comments like that like I just hate
you more than anyone else. Do you think
similarly about support for BB Nyahu?
>> I'm sorry. Do
>> you think similarly about support for BB
Netanyahu?
>> In like similarly in what regard?
>> If you support hatred like if you
support Netanyahu similar to if you
support the Houthies what's woring the
Houthies or support?
>> The Houthies. It's that's so easy. As
much as you like or don't like Israel
like the Israel political establishment
is constrained by the political
realities around them. The big the
biggest issue like how are they con
where's the constraining dude? It's
listen the constraining is if they the
constraining is you know it's a slow
ethnic cleansing instead of a instead of
an a genocide. Okay, that's the
restraining. All right,
I
people will point to Netanyahu as doing
unhinged. Netanyahu will go as far as he
can but not any further. So like if you
have a US president that's restricting
his action to some extent then the
Israeli
>> what happened? Where was the action
restricted? Where was it restricted?
Where was it restricted?
>> Political system will follow and they
have their own internal constraints. Um
the Houthis operate fundamentally on a
totally different
in a totally different way.
>> But hold on, the Houthis are restrained
by reality and the fact that they do not
have the weapons or the ability to cause
harm in the same way that Israel does.
>> If you're going to say that restrictions
and con being constrained are enough to
make somebody good, then the Houthies
are far more restrained than BB
Netanyahu or the Israeli government are.
That's just obvious on its face.
Reality, economics, these things
constrict the Houthies.
I mean, I guess we can run the argument
back of like, well, they can they have I
wouldn't even say they can less people
because isn't the population of Yemen
isn't like million people? How many
people live in Yemen? 39.4 million
people. So, that's not even necessarily
true.
>> Like, it's the same level of support.
Like, yo, go or go Nah.
>> Sorry. Go Houthies or go Nahu.
>> Um, oh yeah, goies. Um,
>> what's worse?
>> Worse, morally worse. O
>> shouldn't even I can't even believe that
this is like delusional. If you've
gotten to this point, you're so lost.
>> Really?
>> For me personally, it's going to be the
Houthies, but it's just that personal
connection. I think morally, I mean,
it's probably
>> I think at least in this respect, even
taking your view, it's kind of a wash.
You just said morally, it might be
>> Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Uh, Kirk,
who's this? Was this?
>> I'm not coming here to tell you that
Connor is correct. I'm telling you to
say I don't feel like you were giving
him the consideration.
>> Okay. But I want to know what you think,
right? So, you you said you would vote
for Kirk before you vote for her. But
I'm also admitting straight up to you
that that might be colored by personal
like it might be colored by personal
things, right? It might be. It would
take more analysis.
>> Is Pisco still collab with Destiny? I
have no idea. Pisco Pisco's leaning
after this. I guarantee you is going to
be we should just debate, right? That's
what he's going to think.
>> I right now I will tell you I would go
Kirk, but that might be colored by
personal reasons. It certainly might be.
>> All right. Well, can we can we discuss
it a little bit? So Sure.
>> Yeah. So in terms of support for
terrorists or support for bad people
abroad, I think Kirk supports Netanyahu
and that's bad. Hassan supports the
Houthies and that's bad. Uh would we
call it a washer? Do we say Nyak is
worse? At least taking your view. I
don't think I can be agnostic about them
and say at least in terms of magnitude
they're both bad to do. Why would you
unless you were willing to make a strong
argument that support is maturely worse
than support for Nanyahu? I think that
at least in your mind it should be a
wash. And so can you name me on some
aspects other than like support for
demons abroad? Like what thing do you
think Kirk is better than Han on?
Um, I think like it was what I opened
with, right? Like I think that there's
like some pillars of our uh
>> Is Destiny going to comment or is he
just going to like listen and say
nothing and just go, "How I can't I
can't believe we've gotten here." Is he
going to give an opinion? I thought the
whole point would be Pisco asked the
question, you give your answer and let
this guy answer that would be left over
after after Kirk got done with it. I
don't think would be left.
>> You think Kirk would support like a like
if you were president? Sorry. If if Kirk
if Trump tried to take over the country
and he was successful in installing
dictation, do you think Kirk would
support it?
If Trump were to take over the country
and try to install dict would would Kirk
support I I would say he probably would.
Yeah.
>> Yeah. So I don't I would say like
there's a highlight.
>> The really easy thing here is just Trump
versus Han,
>> right? If you if you think Hassan is
anywhere near as bad as Donald Trump in
any capacity, you're
believing that like dude, the whole Kirk
versus
>> Yeah. So I don't know like I think I see
the likelihood of
you know support for a fascist takeover
for Kirk is quite high. Do you like but
I feel like the issue I'm having here I
feel like I could just flip the question
and the answer at least.
>> Yeah. I mean Hassan would support an
authoritarian takeover from a leftist
regime as well easily. 100%.
>> My eyes is at least at bare minimum the
same. Right. Like if we do you think
Hassan would support would would Hassan
support like the um the installment of
like a communist dictator. I think
>> hold on hold on hold on hold on.
>> We're operating in reality though. We're
operating in reality. I know the
constraintments of reality are tough,
but in the current political climate,
which one is worse? Obviously, the guy
where the right has like a actual
fascist hold over your country.
>> Yeah, of course.
>> Possibly. But maybe that's a watch, too.
I mean, like I think maybe all watches
out the difference is the difference is
I think Assan has better people around
him. He has bad people around him, too.
But he has some group of people where he
feels a connection to them um that are
tethered to this earth, whereas Kirk is
around the worst demons in the entire
American political system. So, are we
doing like a Trump turn one versus Trump
turn two analysis?
>> H Well, technically Lauren Southern is
on the right, so I can't say they're all
demons. The the woman I love is on the
right, so I can't really say they're all
demons, I guess. What the is this? This
concerned look at saying the people
around Charlie Kirk are evil. Are you
serious?
This is your guy, Kenstyle. This is your
This is your guy right here who's like,
"No, what are you saying? All the people
around Charlie Kirk are bad? What are
you talking about? This is your guy.
He's so spitebased. He hates Pisco so
much that he's about to start arguing."
No, there's some I'm sure there's some
nice people around Charlie Kirk. Charlie
Kirk hangs out with some really cool
guys.
>> This is here like in Trump one, at least
there was like sane people in the room
every once in a while.
>> Uh yeah, I think like except for Kirk.
>> Who are the same people in the room for
Hassan? he's going to have around him
parts of the Trump coalition.
>> And I just don't see like, okay, so
maybe Hassan, if given complete ultimate
power,
>> people destiny thinks are friends, too,
like Adam Freeland. That's the funny
thing.
>> Would institute a communist
dictatorship. I'm not sure. I think, you
know, he's definitely more apt to do it
than any like normal Democrat, for sure.
Um, but I don't know. I just don't like
to to say that you know for certain that
like Kirk is more preferable in terms of
the fascist.
>> That's what I'm telling you. Like I'm
telling you very clearly this might be
colored by personal experience.
might be like for like I don't want to
you know sorry to take it back to this
again but
>> Destiny's just watching he's not even
commenting cuz he knows that if he makes
any comment that backs up anything other
than his facial expressions Piscoll will
rake him over the coals and he will get
completely in the marketplace of ideas
so he can only sit here and go that's
weird that's a weird thing to say I
can't believe how far we've gone cuz he
just has to sit here like a little and
watch Pisco totally own him um what like
I would I mean there's no universe in
which I would argue that it's obviously
horrible that um
>> talking about
>> cuz I think we agree.
>> Switches over to the debate. Okay.
>> I think we agree. Hang on. Let me just
popped out.
>> Sorry, my chat's me the off. So,
>> what were they doing? They're like, "We
okay with corruption."
>> Yeah, they're like they're like, "Yeah,
we love nepatism. Cronyism is my
favorite."
>> Okay.
>> Having the right last name and becoming
a consultant.
>> Oh, you going to watch it from the
beginning now? [__]
>> Have you ever seen Sopranos?
>> Just to be clear, that's not what
nepotism is. Nepotism is not when you're
known as being part of some other family
or whatever and then you get hired as a
place because of your connections or
whatever else. Nepotism is like when
your family members get you a job
because they either like work with the
company or they put in a good word for
you.
>> Actually, nepotism means like when when
your family owns the company, you get a
job because of that. Does it mean like
somebody else gets you like you get a
recommendation from your dad or
something, you get the job? That's not
what that means. Actually,
>> they get you hired like that. this the
idea that nepatism is oh wow wait you're
part of this family that are known for
this thing or whatever oh you know like
you got some skill set or whatever else
because remember Hunter Biden had a
background in all this as well like the
guy was the head of the whatever
>> I I don't even part of the USA and he'
like been on boards and before it's not
like Hunter Biden just walked in
randomly and got this job um like having
a renowned name and then having like
work that's attached to that name isn't
doesn't necessarily count as nepotism
unless you can
>> he doesn't have a renowned name on his
own He openly admits that all of his is
due to his dad. He like he's totally
understanding of that. Dude, we need to
go read that Biden, Inc. article from
Politico that that um that profile they
did. It explains like exactly what
Hunter's attitudes are. Hunter is like
Hunter knows that all of his wealth and
all of his fortune flowed down from his
dad. It's not even like that's the
worst, right? Like that's probably
always going to be the case when you
have a super famous father, right? And a
super famous name. That's like there
aren't other Bidens. There's not like
other Bidens at all basically, right?
This is just naturally what's going to
happen. I didn't like people.
>> Yeah. Like he's got like a JD at Yale
and everything. Like the are we talking
about here?
>> The thing they just love they love
Biden. This we have to understand they
love Biden. Um Oh, wait a second. This
isn't working. Okay. You know what?
We're good. We're good. You're kind of
low for me. I need to turn you up. Okay.
Yeah. Turn me up, bro. Uh
>> chat, let me I'm going to scroll to the
>> I'm gonna get to the Charlie Kirk part
here. I don't really want to watch this
guy all day.
uh Kirk.
>> Problem right now with cozying up to
Charlie Kirk or cozying up to Donald
Trump. The problem right now with
cozying up to Charlie Kirk or cozying up
>> okay as between Charlie Kirk and his son
who's a closer
>> like this is it's not even a real
>> uh Charlie Kirk for the DNC. I mean you
I can't explain this.
>> Who's the closer ally for the DNC?
Charlie Kirk. I knew it was that by the
way. I wasn't sure what we were saying
cuz they went to like, oh, if somebody
was a dictator, who would be better? But
it's like as an ally for the DNC, right?
As an ally for the get onto the t-shirt.
We did that already. Go ahead and leave
and you can come back in a week. Bye.
>> Anything other than you're trying to
>> I'm going to I'm actually just going to
sit on this VOD and watch Destiny like
all day and just laugh at how much of a
fallen he is. Thank you, drama 101. You
know what? Actually, no. I'm going to go
from this to Tech versus Aerodite now.
Okay, that's what we're going to do.
We're going to go watch that entire
Techone Aerodite humanizing interview.
That's what I'm doing now. Thank you.
You've inspired me. All right. Although,
I will need guys. Okay. If you like the
content, if you want more of the content
today, you want maybe that Techite
interview, I need you to dig deep into
your hearts and your wallets and give a
little to the stream. Okay? There's a
couple ways you can do that. You can
donate through TTS. Exclamation boy
donate in the chat. We'll give you the
links. There's Kickbot. There's
Streamlabs. both work. $2 minimum on
Kickbot. $3 minimum on Streamlabs. Every
dollar goes towards more time on the
stream. You see the countdown at the
top. You see the the the meter at the
top. You fill up that meter, we get more
hours on the stream. Okay. If you want
to give subs or if you just want to
donate more money, you don't want your
message on the stream, you can also sub
through kick. You can sub individually.
I love individual subs on kick. That's
my favorite kind of sub. You sub
individually, that's a rolling monthly
charge. I get that income. It's
predictable. It comes back every month.
All right. I love those the most. But
you can also gift subs on kick. All of
it is a 955 split on money. I love it. I
need more of it. Okay, I need more money
on the stream. We are six subs away from
another hour on the stream. Okay, let's
get let's get those bars filled and
let's get more time so we can get that
entire aerodyite techone interview in.
Okay, thank you.
>> Optics right now.
>> Did you see Hutch today again flipped to
no on talking to Queenman? Um maybe
J one guide. Someone said get to the T
topic. I covered the tea topic already.
That's the thing. That's why I was
annoyed. He comes in and he's like,
"Don't talk about this. Talk about what
I want." Yeah. Get the out of here.
>> Gummy donated $10. Woof. Hm. Hm.
>> Thank you very much. Gummy for the 10.
Spruce Willis for the five. The the
gifted sub. Five bucks on the stream.
Thank you guys both very much.
Appreciate it.
>> And then Pisco Pisco loves to do this
thing where he's like, "You guys are
just mad at me because I'm an epic your
fake.
>> Hold on.
>> Even donated $3 when you face reveal.
Any chance you'll wear a fake beard and
a Burger King crown?
>> I don't think so. I would be compelled
to say words that I can't say with my
skin complexion if I've ever face
revealed. Okay, Reuben. Ruben, so I
can't do that. The power of the crown
compels me to say the
>> And then PC Pisco loves to do this thing
where he's like, "You guys are just mad
at me because I'm an epic uh objective
person. You guys are He does like a
thing he's done for like a year at
least." I've heard him say this.
He does a thing where he's like where
he's like I'm an epic logic per uh
Charlie Kirk
>> with a DNC. I mean you I can't explain
this by anything other than you're
trying to optics right now. You know you
>> and then Pisco Pisco loves to do this
thing where he's like you guys are just
mad at me because I'm an epic uh
objective person. You guys are he does
like a thing he's done for like a year
as opposed to Destiny who has done that
thing for like 15 years in a row.
What? What? What? What? What? What?
What? What? This
This guy has never ever gone to say
something and thought, "Wait, how could
this be applied to me?" That's never
crossed his mind a single time in his
entire life. Okay. Holy [__]
>> Yeah, at least I've heard. You guys just
get mad at me because I'm objective here
and you guys are all brainwashed
forever.
>> I have to try to do that. No, no, no.
>> Wow. I can't imagine somebody I can't
imagine somebody trying to say that.
is a better ally to the DNC than
>> like see that see the see the trick he's
playing here and I know he's smart
enough to know this right so it's got
he's
>> no I don't see the what's the trick he
just asked who's the better ally for the
DNC Charlie Kirk or this is like saying
who's the better ally for the DNC
right like he's trying to give an absurd
hypothetical so that if you bite the
bullet and want to say Hassan is bad you
look as you possibly can be right that's
that's the point that's the trick I'm
giving you a bounding question Destiny's
He's well aware of bounding questions to
get the conversation like hey in
principle I am showing you that this is
like the logical principle I'm I'm like
employing right so he's giving a
bounding question like hey obviously it
has to be somebody less conservative
than Charlie Kirk for us to choose uh
Hassan right and Connor goes no I think
I choose Charlie Kirk anyway but
Destiny's pretending he doesn't
understand this concept or he's never
he's never heard of it or seen it or
done it before trying to um he's trying
to Connor he's playing a trick here
right it's not a matter of who's a
closer ally it's what direction do you
head in?
>> I've already answered your question two
or three times.
>> Like the DNC does not have a problem
right now with cozying up to Charlie
Kirk or cozying up to Donald Trump. The
issue is cozying up to crazy leftists
like Hassan. That's the issue.
>> Okay. All right. All right.
>> I again I fail to see which one of these
crazy leftist issues Destiny wasn't on
Hassan side of like 5 years ago, 8 years
ago when these elections were being
held, right? That made people swing
against Democrats. I'm like trans
issues. Destiny was all Destiny was at
the forefront. Destiny's opinion would
have been exactly what the Democrat's
opinion would have been on trans issues
>> politically, which is the vote. If you
want to talk about the vote, obviously
Hassan is more useful to the DNC.
>> Somehow Connor is getting this 100%.
>> than Charlie Kirk. If you're talking
about ideology, which I've mentioned
three times right now, Hassan
wants to see the downfall of the United
States. Charlie Kirk, in my opinion,
thinks that he's fulfilling the promise
of the United States. He's a delusional
freak, but he doesn't want to see the
downfall of the United States of
America.
>> Okay. Um, Destiny loves that, right? Oh,
these people are too much of too too be
judged. Destiny loves that argument,
right? He definitely let that argument
be used for anybody else.
>> I got to be careful what I say next.
Hang on. Let me just think just think.
>> Oh, boy. We're about to hear and leave
in a minute. And I need to read a super
chat as well. So, but make a good point.
Make a good point.
>> This is the DG signaling. I'll respond
to it. I'll read you the super chats and
then we can continue this a different
day. Okay.
I think you have Hassand arrangement
syndrome.
>> I don't.
>> Oh my god.
>> Hassand arrangement, right? And then
it's
>> They don't think he's that bad. This is
it. This is it. This is it. They just
>> We don't We don't We don't think he's
that bad. I think Assan's pretty bad. I
think Assan's pretty stupid, but I don't
think um I don't think having a good
relationship with Hassan is the downfall
of the DNC.
I don't think trying to have a good
relationship with Hassan is the downfall
of the DNC. I think that's an
embarrassing point to make. And I think
saying that if the DNC was trying to
reach towards Charlie Kirk or Hassan,
which which of those two creators which
of those two creators audiences could
they more easily court? It's obviously
Hassan's. I don't think he's that bad.
>> No, Hassan's pretty bad. Hassan's like
I'm sure if I if anybody ever felt the
need to link me Hassan clips of him
saying, I would go, "Oh my god, this
guy's a
but I just don't think he's like Charlie
Kirk levels of evil." And Charlie Kirk
is complicit in the fascist takeover of
your country. I'm not going to compare
Hassan to that because I'm not a [__]
either on that front. I'm not a [__] on
the uh I'm not like ideologically
captured. Not even a [__] I'm not so
ideologically captured that I have to
like say, "Oh no, Hassan's worse than
Charlie Kirk."
Wasn't Destiny on his Jan 6 arc and
going on about the all the Trump
supporters not being American and being
traitors? How can he justify Kirk as
better than Han? He literally justified
a Trump supporter getting shot in the
head in front of his kids because he was
at a Trump rally.
Charlie Kirk is like the head
cheerleader of the Trump rallies.
I don't know. I don't know what to I
don't know what to say or do. I'm just
going to make more kitty jokes and kid
jokes and eventually I guess maybe I
need other people to do it with me at
some point. I guess it gets normalized
and nobody cares anymore, huh? Is that
Is that all it is? Is that like I just I
should just do it more and then
eventually it's like just not a big
deal. What's like the most
>> Wait, what did he did he just Wait, what
did he just say? I just missed it.
>> I don't know what to I don't know what
to say or do. I'm just going to make
more kitty jokes and kid jokes and
eventually I got
>> Okay,
>> maybe I need other people to do it with
me at some point. I guess it gets
normalized and nobody cares anymore,
huh? Is that
>> Yeah, I actually I actually fully
advocate you taking that path, Destiny.
Okay. Yes. Keep talking about kids. Keep
talking about kids, Destiny. That's what
you got to do. Okay. There's no there's
nobody on the internet who's basically
suggesting that you might be a already.
Okay. We could we could up those
numbers. We We can make everybody think
you're a I believe you can get there.
Okay, let's go. Destiny is going to
normalize, guys. That's his mission.
He's going to make you think that
habitual consent violation is just
gooning culture. And he's also going to
make you think that are just maps. Okay,
don't get on Destiny for being in those
minor attracted person Discords. Okay,
it's all fine.
Oh, this
>> is Is that all it is? Is that like I
just I should just do it more and then
eventually it's like just not a big
deal. What's like the most I could joke
about?
>> I did one a little bit ago on some
maggot people. I'll just keep doing
this, I guess, every single day and then
eventually we can just keep pushing.
>> Yes. Yes. Oh, he's going to win. Yes.
Let's go it further and further and
further and it's
dude. And here's the sad thing. He's
getting like abouths. He's right
spamming in the chat. Pisco becoming a
Hassan Orbiter was not on my bingo card.
The people in his chat are literally too
dumb to be able to go, "Oh, wait. That
seems crazy. Destiny, Destiny, that
seems crazy. Are we really doing this?"
Dude, I I would love to have a
conversation with August at this point
and just know where his head's at when
he watches like this clip. And he's
like, "Okay, okay. I guess we're going
to we're going to up the kid talk."
Okay. All right. All right. All right.
Uh-huh. Uh-huh. What's like the most
unhinged I could joke about? I did one a
little bit ago on some mag people. I'll
just keep doing this, I guess, every
single day and then eventually we can
just keep pushing it further and further
and further and it's
I don't at all. I don't. Why? Why the
I think you have a lack of I think you
have a devotion syndrome.
>> Yes. True.
>> Yes. Oh, Destiny's going to feel really
mad when he sees when he sees Connor
totally cower away from that statement
the second Pisco is about to respond.
Connor literally himself and cowers away
from that statement completely the
second Pisco goes to respond. I am 100%
vindicated in Hassan's story. Why? How?
Because I found out they got kicked out
of Global Entry. That that doesn't even
that doesn't cut in any way, size,
shape, or form. It's like, well, I know
that he got
That's not It's all about the reason he
was cut from Global Entry. What? I know
he lost Global Entry because of his
political views. How do you know that?
What? Like
>> all All Destiny would have to do is just
argue this. By the way, I say that you
don't know that for sure, too. Pisco
gives a percentage. All you'd have to do
is argue.
>> Meanwhile, every piece of evidence cuts
against his son, right? Oh, he was
kicked out of Global before he came back
to the United States. Oh, okay. Oh, he
was kicked out like two days after uh
the Houthies were declared a a terrorist
organization and Hassan was tweeting out
kind of death threats.
>> Wait, but hold on. Those are political
opinions, right? His his opinion on the
Houthies is a political opinion.
>> Scott Oh, we find out that um Hassan's
stay at um the interrogation wasn't 2
hours. It was 15 minutes and Hassan
didn't even give a when people corrected
him on it. Like every piece of evidence
cuts against him. That doesn't cut
against him at all. The how long he was
interrogated for doesn't cut against him
at all. Wait, but if you ask today, he
would
Pesco's problem is for political views
Hassan was targeted to have this
privilege removed. That's the whole
point. It doesn't matter how much of a
baby back Hassan is. Not doesn't matter
how much of a diva he is when he
overmbellishes every bad thing that's
ever happened to him. That is irrelevant
to the fiscal analysis. Still say, "Oh
yeah, I'm 100% confident that Hassan was
politically targeted at the board."
He'll still he would I guarantee he
holds that position still today.
>> I don't. Why? Why the I think you have a
lack of I think you have Hassan devotion
syndrome. Okay. You have the bottom on
him. No, I just I just took the Trump
devotion syndrome and I inverted it. Uh,
hold on. Hold up. Hold up.
>> Yes, Connor. Yes. Yes. Oh. Oh, he um Oh.
Oops. Oops. Oh. Oh.
>> In what world should you,
>> dude?
go. Oh my god.
At what point do you think I I gave
Destiny this advice yesterday? Okay,
Destiny's best course of action here is
to say, you know what, Pisco, you were
right on this one. And to cut this tie
entirely because every time he fights
with Pisco, people are going to realize
Pisco is more correct. Pisco is cooler.
Pisco can actually grow a beard. Pisco
is based. Pisco is awesome. He hasn't
violated anybody's consent. Okay, people
are just every time you cover Pisco and
try to see about him, people are going
to realize he's way better than you and
you're going to lose more of your
audience every single time because Pisco
owns you. Okay, it's over. Pisco has a
college degree. Pisco actually is
disciplined. Pisco can actually work
hard. Pisco is capable of great things
and Destiny is not. Admit just know your
betters, Destiny. Okay, know who owns
you. Pisco owns you. And if you go after
him, you will continue to get owned.
>> Cater to a human being who says that
it's good to missiles into civilian
commercial vessels in
>> I don't even I don't I can't even
believe that Connor has to ask this
question. I It's like this is such an
unhinged insane conversation right now.
>> I'm not saying that's good. No, I'm not
saying that that's good. I'm saying as
between Charlie Kirk and Hassan, Charlie
Kirk is incredibly illiberal. I don't
even know if Charlie Kirk has said
anything on that level because at least
like Republicans kind of sort of a or at
least the ones around Trump kind of sort
of have to kind of play a little bit of
a game.
Uh again, we're seeing that like Israel
is the dividing line here for some
reason. It's not America. It's not how
these people act in America. It's not
how they violate your constitution. It's
not how they support the violation of
your constitution. Right? It is Israel.
If you are mean to Israel, that is
enough to say you're not American. Why?
I don't know. Why is Charlie Kirk less a
liberal than Hassan? Why is Charlie Kirk
better than Hassan? Well, I don't know.
Certainly not for America.
>> How does this guy write a docu? He
literally said he was recording his
January 6th documentary lines yesterday.
How the did he do that documentary and
go, "Yeah, this Republican, he's way
better than he he's way better than Han.
I take him over Han any day. This guy
totally supports this. This guy who has
no problem totally sucking Trump's now.
>> Cool.
>> Kirk is not a liberal. Charlie Kirk is a
fascist. He's part of this like youth
movement in our country. Uh I I think
he's I think he's so
>> by the way, Destiny, the youth movement
that your entire thing on America is
based on that he is evil, that he is
destroying America and you're reaching
back out to the youth. You should hate
Charlie Kirk, you idiot.
Dude,
that's like the entire premise of
America is Charlie Kirk is destroying
America. He is America.
He has to respond to what Pisco just
said. You'd think so. The socialists and
because of the revolution. Oh, whoops.
Whoops. I went too far forward.
>> Anything on that level? Because at least
like Republicans kind of sort of a or at
least the ones around Trump kind of sort
of have to kind of play a little bit of
a game. Are you getting all emotional?
Um, it's 50% real that I'm like shocked
that this person is so incapable of
logical argument, dude. And 50%
performance for the stream. And I'm also
I'm going to lose my voice. You consider
that Charlie Kirk hasn't been that mean
to Destiny recently. Him and Aronite
have like the same thing, right? Oh,
these people are mean to me. That means
they're evil.
Amazing. That was that me? Was that
everybody? Okay. Another example of
morals downstream from Politica. Okay.
Oh, dude. Do you think Destiny is
starting to realize that like these
allies are ones he can't defend? Like
he's always kind of like defended his
orbiters a little bit, defended
forthought even when it was like a
little bit of a hit. Do you think he's
starting to realize that like the Mantis
Aerodite counterpoints,
Mantis Aerodite counterpoints, Tom Fury
tier of of orbiters, these ones, Darius,
these are the ones where it's like, oh,
you know what? I might have to cut my
losses. I might have to go it alone now.
This actually this is not tenable
anymore. I don't know. I don't know,
guys. I don't know if this is good.
Do you not think that Hassan actually
supports a more authoritarian type of
communism than actually aligns with the
DNC? Uh, yeah. Yeah. No, I think Hassan
would probably in his ideal world do
that. But Hassan wants to build towards
socialism or he whatever. Right. Uh
here's the other thing. I actually don't
know Apollo's Heights. What I'd like is
for every DJer to check one of the two
boxes. Okay. Is Hassan a hyper
capitalist, hyper consumerrist, as
Destiny would say, who actually loves
capitalism more than anybody or is he at
his heart like a total chic tanky piece
of which one is it? Right?
You have to pick one. He can't be both
at the same time. So, if you want to say
that he's this covert tanky who hides
his power level and he is actually
because I believe that he's got some of
those beliefs, but I think they're
performance and he is just a consumer,
right? He is like a hyperconsumer guy, I
think that's more accurate, right? But
if you want to argue that he's going to
actually institute communism in America,
then you have to argue the opposite. And
then you have to explain why he does all
of the um all of the consumer things,
all the capitalist things. You can't he
can't be a grifter and somebody who will
overthrow the US government. He cannot
be both.
Apollos Heights. Do you think he doesn't
understand that other under like
socialism or under communism he wouldn't
have the things he has?
I don't think that's true. I think I
think he is way too I think everything
about his personality points towards him
being a narcissist and like a diva and
that he could never survive in a world
where he is like equal to his peers.
That that would drive him insane. But
that's me.
Charlie Kirk is not a liberal. Charlie
Kirk is a fascist. He's part of this
like youth movement in our country. Uh I
I think he's I think he's so
>> Yes. So Hassan is at worst like somebody
like a champagne socialist. Charlie Kirk
is actively supporting the like downfall
of your country's democracy and you're
going to equate these things. You're
going to make these people equal.
Destiny's going to make these people
equal. Really? He might just be self-d
deluding.
>> Like, ironically enough, part of the
reason why people ended up going with in
Germany is because
Uhhuh.
Okay. Is this going to be because the
socialists were really unreasonable or
something? Is that
He did the thing earlier, too, in that
clip. Watch
>> He's part of this like youth movement in
our country.
>> Uh I I think he's I think he's so He
might just be self-d deluding.
>> How far back could I go?
>> Ironically enough, part of the reason
why people ended up going with in
Germany is because they were afraid of
the socialists and because of the
revolution with Lenin and the Soviet
Union in Russia. Like that is part of
the reason why people ended up going
with the they're saying this like it's
incredible that anybody made that
decision. Nobody likes either of these
groups of people.
Is Hassan like Lenin? Is Hassan like
actual socialists from the 30s and 40s?
Is the sound like that? They're both
horrible.
Destiny, that means you're
Well, we did see the haircut from
earlier in the stream, right? I don't
know who got who got to him and told him
like, "Hey, dude, your hair is like
actually you look like you own a panel
van." Okay. An unmarked panel van. You
give out candy in front of a school,
right? Isn't that from ear? Yeah. This
like comb over. You look like you own an
unmarked panel van. You give out like
candy in front of a school. Okay. So, he
fixed his hair. He ruffled it up or
something. But this is the haircut. He
had it going. He actually had it going
earlier as we go further back. Right.
Hold on. Let's go. Let's go back to
here. Maybe.
>> Yeah. He really had it going.
Damn. Okay, we'll go back.
>> Also, Charlie Kirk is more of a quote
unquote liberal like liberalism. Charlie
Kirk is more of a liberal than Hassan
is. Even though like Charlie Kirk would
support fascism under Trump. He's
already proven as much. He would.
Charlie Kirk would win.
>> Yeah. Yes. Wait, did he just say the
thing that should make him not want to
pick Charlie Kirk?
>> Charlie Kirk is more of a liberusal.
>> Also, Charlie Kirk is more of a
quoteunquote liberal. Like liberalism.
Charlie Kirk is more of a liberal than
Hassan is. Even though
>> Okay, hold on. Let him cook. Let him
cook. Like Charlie Kirk would support
fascism under Trump. He's already proven
as much. He would. Charlie Kirk win.
I What? Huh?
Did I miss something? That is part of
the reason why people ended up.
>> They're both thing.
>> They're both horrible.
>> Also, Charlie Kirk is more of a quote
unquote liberal like liberalism. Charlie
Kirk is more of a liberal than Hassan
is. Even though like Charlie Kirk would
support fascism under Trump's already
proven as much he would. Charlie Kirk
would
but made president. Would Charlie Kirk
choose fascism on his own? I'm not
actually sure. I don't know. I don't
think
>> Oh, he's going this way would. But I
think these guys will will go along with
it with
[Music]
>> um this is a very interesting argument
on its own. There's a very
Oh boy.
Would Hassan support fascis? Well, his
thing would be that if Hassan was if
Hassan could hit a button and make it
communism in America, Hassan would hit
that button. And he's saying, but if
Charlie Kirk could make it fascism in
America, he might not hit that button. I
don't know. Here's the thing. Based on
their actual real world actions, I don't
know if I believe that. Rhetorically, I
I think Hassan would tell us he clicked
that button to make actual communism
happen, right? I think Hassan would tell
us that he clicked that button. I don't
know if he would, though.
And Charlie Kirk is clearly taking steps
to allow fascism to flourish in America.
Jtock, should anyone be allowed to run
against Democrats? What's the argument
for democracy if everyone who disagrees
with you is evil? I don't think everyone
who disagrees with me is evil. I think
there's a lot of Republicans who aren't
evil. I think they happen to have a
weird offset, like a weird plurality in
that party where Trump can win the
Republican primaries and everybody else
falls in line because they have no
spine. I don't think everybody on that
side of the aisle is evil. Never thought
that. And you talked to basically
everybody on that side of the aisle.
Where did you think that I was arguing
that they're all evil?
I said Charlie Kirk is evil. Charlie
Kirk is evil. Charlie Kirk sells out his
country. Charlie Kirk's a piece of [__]
Please don't take my arguing for over
Charlie Kirk as an endorsement of
Hassan. Please don't. Please don't.
Please understand that I am only doing
this in reaction to Charlie Kirk being
the other person.
Here's the thing. I hate Destiny. If you
gave me If you give me Hassan versus
Destiny and who could be president, I'd
pick Destiny.
I don't think I'd pick him for like a
fascist thing. But like president or who
you who you court for like your
political movement, I'd pick Destiny.
And it's not to say that because I hate
this person, right?
But I'm I'm not sitting here like
shilling for Hassan.
I think Hassan is just not anywhere near
as bad as these people are trying to
make him to seem to like try to I don't
even know what their goal is. I don't
know what the goal is anymore. It's
totally disingenuous.
[__] Trump, which is I don't even
Maybe that's worse. It's disgusting. It
shows lack of spine. But Assan made
dictator. It's not like Assan is
following anybody right now. It's not
like Assan is an excuse to be an actual
terrorist comes slurp, right? He's he's
doing it all on his own. sometimes to
his detriment. Charles,
>> no, it's it's all the it's all the Oh,
it's all the stupid um oppressor
oppressed narrative.
>> Kirk worships Trump and follows Trump to
the ends of the earth. Why? Because it's
made him one of the most prominent
political people in the United States.
Hassan
>> come slurping ticulous sunset. It's hard
to say. We take a shot though. I need to
go get some alcohol and take a shot. Oh,
hold on. What is this? It's a audio
thing.
What if I told you that Steven regularly
has
>> No, I'm not.
>> All of the enemies of the United States
of America. That That's actually pretty
understandable if you're not terrorists,
like actual terrorists. Not even like
good enemies. Not even like China,
Russia. I don't know if I say Russia's a
good one, but at least it's better than
Islamic extremists. That's some that was
supposed to be go out of favor after
911. What the [__]
>> Yeah. Return back. The last thing I'll
say is I think that is this like uh
>> Yes. I think that is
>> Is this really the best we can do? This
is the best we can do.
Islam Islamic extremists are worse than
China or Russia, guys. He doesn't even s
for cool enemies like China or Russia.
He simps for Islamic extremists.
Uhhuh. It's almost like he has a some
sort of principled principled opposition
to the state of Israel. It's almost like
you could almost say this is downstream
of a principled opposition to the way
Israel manages the the occupation of
Gaza and in the West Bank. It's almost
like that he does also s for China. Yes.
No, he absolutely ss for China. I don't
know why he would say that actually. I
don't even know why Destiny said that.
Yeah, he absolutely ss for China hard. I
don't think he ss for Russia as hard. I
think people make up how much he ss for
Russia. Um but I I do think he ss for
China hardcore. So
>> at the end of the day like there's a
greater enemy here.
>> Who's your enemy?
>> Charlie Charlie Kirk and his ilk bag is
my enemy.
>> That's my main enemy.
>> MAGA is my enemy. My enemy also
>> is also No, I actually I probably This
is probably the sincere difference
between us. My enemy is also the far
left and half of progressivism
>> simultaneously. I have two enemies.
>> Equal. Who's your greater enemy? Well, I
think you already said it. Your greatest
enemy by
>> by the way, progressivism was a greater
cultural enemy over the past decade.
MAGA is clearly the bigger uh the bigger
political threat right now.
>> But but just because like uh Henry
Kissinger, he says like it's a shame
that both can't lose. I'm fighting for a
center left center right coalition
because I want and I want the far left
to lose.
>> Gunhead, you'll pick the fascist over
the the commie.
>> Yep.
>> Yep. I I unironically like in u in
Chile, I will unironically pick Buchelle
and uh
>> fascist over commi. I don't necessarily
disagree on that. Fascist over commi
maybe. Okay.
But like Charlie Kirk versus Assad,
that's pretty easy. Like you take the
worst version of fascism, the hardest
version of fascism, the hardest version
of communism. I might take the fascist
over the communists. I'm not totally
sure. Okay.
Fascists look pretty cool. All right,
I'll say that. But in the in the actual
thing we're comparing and the actual
actions they've taken in the world,
trying to compare Hump and Charlie Kirk
is insane. It's it's just nuts. Buchell
and what's the other guy? Um, Chile.
He's the dictator. He's got three people
out of airplanes. What was his name?
>> It's so funny that both of these
ideologies like suck so much
>> like communists were supposed to deliver
like freedom to for the workplace and
the ability to own your own business and
all this and all their people are poor
and starving and they suck and just
massive failure in every level and they
all became authoritarian dictatorships
anyway. And then fascism was supposed to
be like the military mightiest racially
pure societ. and all of them like lose
their first major war.
>> Uh I don't think Italy's thing was not
racial puress. That's not what fascism
was about, right?
>> Just like go extin. It's just
>> they for what they're supposed to be
accurate.
>> Holy.
>> Um talking about
>> Pino. I would pick Pinoch and Buchelle
over Maduro and a Yande
>> probably.
All right. What is this? What is this?
What is this?
You're like, "But but even cared about
Germany or something."
>> Okay. Okay.
Some super chats. Yeah. Um